[Musique]
nous sert ligne bonsoir ça nous pensons
qu'ils s'appellent thinker view jour
soit pour parler d'effondrement tout un
tas de choses connecter avec ce sujet
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
eh bien j'ai
je suis face à une formation
scientifique
en ce moment je fais plutôt des
conférences j'écris des articles des
livres
je suis papa de deux enfants
voilà et j'habite dans les montagnes
j'ai quitté la ville il ya trois ans
voilà fait que l'écologie
j'ai fait vrai dans mes études c'était
j'ai commencé par agronomie renault me
des régions tropicales et puis ça m'a
vite déçu en fait ainsi qu'aux que
j'attendais
l'agriculture comme ca conventionnel
puis en fait l'option tropicale c'était
marrant parce que c'était le
développement donc on nous les petits
blancs on allait développer les épis
binois tropicaux c'était pas trop ma
conception des choses du coup j'ai eu la
chance parce que j'ai trouvé un prof de
zoologie qui m'a initié aux fourmis du
coup j'ai fait de la recherche c'est mon
rêve d'adolescent et j'ai pu me brancher
sur la recherche de sur le comportement
des fourmis puis j'ai enchaîné un dea
épine thèse sur les fourmis
que c'est l'algorithme de la fourmi non
non non moi sur ce sujet [__]
pourquoi ce sujet de l'effondrement
comment ça vous est venue alors ça ça
arrive et en quelle année c'est un
déclic c'était un éclair de lucidité
c'est donc voilà ça a été plusieurs
déclic c'est venu plus tard en fait j'ai
fini ma thèse en 2008 j'ai pas continuer
la recherche et du coup j'avais déjà en
lisant tous les comme je bossais sur
l'écologie l'évolution l'éthologie tous
ces thèmes là j'étais
abreuvés de publication de chiffres sur
la biodiversité le climat j'avais touché
un peu à l'énergie tout ça la politique
j'étais assez engagé en tout cas
politiquement du coup quel bord
libertaire anarchiste pendant dizaine
d'années donc j'avais deux vies
parallèles en fait puis se sont un peu
touchés rejoint et et puis ouais voilà
la conscience du monde quand j'ai eu 20
ans je me suis conscientiser j'ai
commencéà
je peux pas me positionner par rapport
au monde etc et puis est en fait en
quittant en 2008 la recherche j'ai
trouvé enfin une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai arrêté la recherche
fondamentale
c'était que c'était pas assez engagé
dans le monde fin jeu c'était super
comme métier j'ai étudié les fourmis et
c'est magnifique qui sauf que so what
quoi qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça et du
coup en sortant j'ai j'ai fait de
l'éducation populaire c'est à dire que
ce que je savais faire c'était écrire
des articles et parler aux gens faire
des powerpoint et voilà analyser
synthétiser errants et rendre
12 plus intelligible ouais voilà et
et puis les déclics c'était
j'avais cette mauvaise non pas
pressentiment mes mauvaises sensations
que voient les choses vont pas bien et
puis le grand déclic c'était le livre de
rob hopkins manuel de transition parce
que là et c'était le premier qui faisait
la connexion entre le climat et le pic
pétrolier que je de sujet que je connais
c'est comme ça un peu séparément mais le
déclic ça a été de les rassembler hélas
tous tous et interconnectés et je me
suis dit attends il ya un truc trop
énorme donc il ya eu l'avant et l'après
en quelque sorte un grand choc et puis
j'ai dit à mes collègues de l'éducation
populaire c'est une association à liège
qui s'appelle barricades il faut qu'on
se fait là dessus on a fait participer à
l'émergence du mouvement de la
transition en belgique le livre du coup
a été traduit en français c'était 2008
en anglais je crois et 2010 en français
et on est tout de suite parti là dessus
ça m'a passionné et
le thème de l'effondrement alors c'était
pas encore là à l'époque mais je crois
que c'est en deux ans après j'ai fait
une étude sur l'agriculture sans pétrole
donc je mets ma formation en agronomie
et coller au pic pétrolier ça donne quoi
et du coup les agronomes en fait il
parlait souvent de peut-être la fin des
énergies fossiles mais sans plus c'était
1-2 c'est dans les powerpoint voilà
peut-être c'est un risque et puis les
spécialistes du pic pétrolier parce que
du coup j'allais à des colloques je suis
participer à la spo l'association pour
l'étude du pic pétrolier de gaz en
belgique
et puis eux c'est vous connaissez le
denier les grandeurs non non gand
belgique et ce truc là dont une en
suisse non j'ai pas connu en suisse et
du coup eux c'était pareil il est des
powerpoint en disant bon voilà il y aura
des problèmes dans l'économie puis un
tir est l agriculture et pas de
connexion du coup j'ai fait une étude
pour barrick est sur l'agriculture ils
ont sans pétrole pour moi c'était un
déclic parce que j'amorce est déjà d une
réflexion qui était
nouvel an en europe parce que j'ai vu en
belgique en belgique ans aux états unis
avaient déjà des deux trois penseurs des
centres le je pense aland institute avec
west jackson qui travaillait là dessus
il développer des nouvelles techniques
de traction animale c'était c'était fou
pour un agronome et même des céréales
pérenne des céréales qui doivent pas se
redonner enfin c'était génial et en
europe rien j'ai même demandé je me
souviens à une conférence à michel
griffon inde est un des grands penseurs
de l'agriculture de l'agronomie en
france et je crois directeur adjoint de
la recherche de l'agencé nationale pour
la recherche entre comme ça et puis je
lui posais une question après sa
conférence jeudi et
l'agriculture sans pétrole post pétrole
le regard effet elle c'est intéressant
j'ai jamais vu ça sous cet angle et je
suis demandé ce qui est des labos de
recherche qui en europe travaille
là-dessus non du coup ça m'a voilà ça me
ça m'a motivé à mettre là dessus et
alors j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
après l'institut momen tout mais il y
avait coché niais sinaï et caetera et
m'ont invité à faire ses recherches ella
a présenté ses recherches par nous et là
c'était quoi c'était ben oui c'est yves
qui m'arrive cochet qui m'a
demandé du coup de faire un rapport pour
le parlement européen le groupe les
verts
sur l'avenir de l'agriculture en europe
où c'était super mon sujet je me suis
lâché j'ai eu ma fille m'a dit sous
l'angle de la résilience alors la
résidence la capacité de se remettre des
chocs pour un système ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que si on parle de
résidence ou parle de catastrophe donc
il m'a dit ta carte blanche et là je me
suis fait plaisir donc j'ai été voir en
climatologie en biodiversité en pétrole
et comme j'étais payé pour ça j'ai pris
rct dans les 2000 et quelques un truc
comme ça brut note pour rappel plus
j'essaie plus et
il m'a et du coup j'ai pris en été je me
suis pour il était avec ma compagne et
on avait
pressé tu rêves non c'est pourri l'été
parce que enfin moi ça m'a bouleversé
j'avais d'état des piles d'articles
comme ça et tous les jours tous les
jours en pleine vacances avec les bébés
tout ça c'était c'était dur enfin jean
neige et j'ai perdu 6 kilos je me
souviens et après voilà pendant quatre
mois je me suis gavé tout ça des pieds
en trois semaines ses sorties ce rapport
et ça fait un petit buzz parce qu'à
l'époque
olivier de ce critère là qui était
rapporteur des nations unies pour le
droit à l'alimentation fatigue habite à
bruxelles je le connaissais je lui
envoie le rapport il m'a fait c'est
super et m'a soutenu au parlement et du
coup il ya un éditeur qui est venu me
voir et et moi j'avais donné toutes mes
tripes tout tout mon coeur fait un tout
dans ce rapport et j'étais content du
coup un éditeur venu me voir un petit
éditeur il m'a dit faut en faire un
bouquin et c'est marrant parce que à
partir du moment où il ya une boucle on
a commencé à m'écouter c'est bizarre
parce que avant quand il ya eu un
rapport c'est en pdf c'est un rapport on
s'en fout c'est un langage un langage
technocratique
ben il n'y a pas tellement de vin
d'impact même pour la famille les amis
montent à faire rapport au roi tu perds
et puis le bouquin ça change le regard
des gens et à partir de ce moment là on
a commencé à + m'inviter dans les
conférences et de fil en aiguille
d'article en article de confiance et 14
en 2013 le rapport et le livre du coup
il est paru en 2014 donc de 2009 à 2013
il ya eu tous ceux enfin ça a mûri quoi
et après ça s'est assez bien enchaîné
depuis 2013 devrait pas refluer pression
dessus du bouquin
dépression j'en ai fait une pause dans
ma thèse mais c'était ça avait rien à
voir la dépression
dans tous ces déclic
c'est énorme ce que j'ai fait la liste
des déclics sais je vous invite à le
faire d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent
de des moments où on se fige on lit
quelque chose en fait [__]
et là on part en voilà il ya l'avant et
l'après est en fait j'en ai liste et 30
ou 40 j'ai noté à chaque fois l'émotion
qu'avait j'ai noté le ce qui s'est passé
en revue en revoyant dans le rétroviseur
c'est assez
impressionnant et le moment de
dépression s'était mais ça je le raconte
souvent c'est quand j'ai interviewé
dennis meadows le coauteur du rapport au
club de rome il était venu en 2011 en
france
2011 soit pour présenter la traduction
du troisième rapport
traduction français que je conseille
d'ailleurs et puis lui disait partout
j'avais à libé le monde
il disait voilà il parler d'effondrement
il était trop tard nous suit un petit
c'était il est trop tard pour le
développement durable énorme comme outil
comme titre et
ça a choqué les gens moi j'étais super
content qu'ils puissent le dire il a été
invité à l'institut moman tourne
d'ailleurs et et alors là les négos
c'était marrant parce que j'étais en
belgique et je vais faire un article
pour le
magazine écologistes
l'écologie politique belge qui s'appelle
imaginent demain le monde et d'ailleurs
il est publié en france faire bref et
est donc je dis aux rédac'chef vous
allez voir de nice met dos c'est fou ce
qu'il dit
ok vas-y tu l'interview je vais à la
conférence de presse le matin et j'étais
tout seul en fait ce jour là ce matin là
le roi avait convoqué tous les
journalistes parce qu est nommé un
nouveau gouvernement au gouvernement et
belgique venait de de passer deux ans
sans gouvernement et du coup tous les
jours ni son parti je me retrouvais 2h
ou 3h avec dennis meadows après j'ai dû
amener quelque part il se trouve que
j'allais enfin j'ai passé la journée
avec lui et j'avais eue je venais de
lire tous les rapports ça m'avait ou et
voilà pendant peut-être deux trois mois
après j'étais vraiment mal on a bien
discuté en aller au fond des choses vie
nous a dit des choses paris m'a dit des
choses bien bien profondes enfin bien
sûr le fait que ça fait 40 ans qu'il
dise à
personnes l'écoutent fin il y revenait
d'allemagne c'était marrant et il avait
vu à tout plein de groupes de leca
sombre ouais c'est ça ouais mais là une
vidéo fonctionnaires il avait vu des
gens importants voilà un peu qu'il est
politiquement scientifiquement fin dans
les milieux scientifiques politiques et
puis 10 m et atteint les allemands ils
se préparent à des chocs importants
enfin il ya des revenus derrière à
commencer
puisqu'il m'avait dit disait il imprime
les deutschemark en masque alors que
c'est à l'euro et de personnes en
parlent que voilà et puis en allemagne
enfin il je suis plus qu'il ya un an ou
un an et demi
il ya l'info qui était sorti que
il donne le gouvernement demandé à la
population de faire des vivres pour au
moins deux semaines d'avoir deux
semaines d'autonomie chez soi c'est une
info énorme enfin il ya d'ailleurs un
pays faux fax etc et ça d'ailleurs mais
il ya un pays nordique récemment il ya
genre quatre ou cinq mois qui a fait la
même déclaration mais pour deux pour
plus que deux semaines ça c'est le sud
qui se prépare la guerre ok et
ben voilà donc c'est des infos qui voilà
qui sortent sur édition des signaux
faibles j'ouvris parenthèse pour nos
auditeurs et spectateurs on part pour
une longue interview donc si vous bien
profondément gmac siège n'est pas
d'invité après la la c'est un sujet on
va creuser trop fou et on a commencé en
retard et est en plus par parma foot on
va commencer en retard
et auditeurs et auditrices bien entendu
pablo
ce cet éclair de lucidité quant aux
fondamentaux de soutenabilité sociétale
quand tu si on peut se tutoyer
attends tu les aborde avec tes proches
parce que tu peux me décrire ton
approche selon les différents cercles
autour de toi alors le cercle proche
d'afam tes enfants
ta grand mère ton certes un peu plus
élargie ton meilleur pote est du bon
aussi tu veux aussi comment ça se passe
tout à bord de ce problème comment
tranquillement bon alors là ça a un peu
changé avant et après les livres c'est à
dire que avant justement ce déclic de la
publication des livres c'est vrai qu'on
prenait un peu pour un fou pour un
emmerdeur pour voilà c'était ça partait
vite en blague je voyais tout temps doux
ouais enfin bon moi je sais faire des
blagues là dessus donc c'était pas tant
ça c'était ça partait sur des blagues et
puis on arrêter d'en parler et puis
parfois s'il y avait des petits des
petites fissures dans la conversation
des petits éclairs des petits parfois
pendant je sais pas quelques minutes
avec les amis avec la famille bas on
parlait je passe de gmc intéressés du
coup j'en parlais et puis et puis on
oubliait fin voilà c'était c'était pas
facile avec ma compagne bah j'ai eu de
la chance tu es assez graduel du coup ça
ça n'a pas fait péter les choses mais je
sais qu'il ya des amis pour qui c'est
c'est un sujet toxiques ça a fait péter
des couples
c'est et des amitiés enfin voila c'est
c'est normal c'est un gros sujet ça
bouleverse les représentations qu'on a
de l'avenir de 2 to
alors maintenant à depuis la publication
des livres ça a changé parce que union
catatonie émotionnel
ouais non mais ça rend crédible aussi un
discours il ya eu il ya eu sa mort du
coup moi j'ai eu plus d'expérience pour
en parler
j'aborde enfin je sais m'adapter au
public je sais et puis à les livres qui
sont là du coup ça fait sérieux et ceux
qui l'ont lu du ca les laisse libres de
parler de d'aborder le sujet que moi et
donc moi je laborde volontiers mais si
on laborde pas je vais pas forcer les
choses je ne force jamais en fait
cherche pas à convaincre pas
l'impression d'être entouré de zombies
non pas tellement
enfin chez mais là aussi il ya un billet
parce que à chaque fois je fais une
conférence et a plein de gens qui
viennent les salles sont combles et
c'est je reçois beaucoup de messages
tard que j'arrive pas à trier à lire des
messages magnifique de soutien etc donc
ouais il ya un billet parce que
peut-être gens voient moins des gens
incrédules en fait je vois beaucoup de
gens qui croient ça ça me touche et on
est vraiment nombreux quoi d'aidé enfin
dans les conférences mais par internet
il ya vraiment beaucoup de gens qui vont
cette intuition qui comprennent qu'ils
se mettent à croire qu'ils se mettent à
cheminer et qui font tout ces points
croire
là parce qu'on pense qu'à une différence
entre savoir et croire c'est ce que dit
très bien jean pierre dupuy le
philosophe c'est à dire qu'on a tous les
chiffres tout est là il suffit dérape un
rapport du giec de lire plein de trucs
chiants sur internet enfin il faut un
peu se voilent à se forcer on rassemble
des données ont fait tourner les
méninges tout est là enfin tout est là
mais c'est dur de lire ça c'est dur ça
veut dire
il faut il faut de la persévérance faut
du courage pour une stabilité
émotionnelle
voilà et puis à un moment on sait sauf
qu'il ya des gens qui savent mais qui
croît pas
pourquoi mais ça c'est en en parlant le
bouquin c'est tous les ressorts de la
psyché humaine c'est à dire qu'on est
devant un fait
l'être humain il est incroyable il
préfère renoncer aux faits mais garder
ses croyances plutôt que de changer ses
croyances pour les accorder ou fait un
exemple c'est le les économistes ils ont
été formés pour la croissance pourrait
tout l'économie est faite pour et par la
croissance il y croit c'est vraiment une
braise comme une religion quoi est il ya
un fait qui arrive par exemple le pic
pétrolier et alors là avec les lunettes
de la croissance c'est un oui je
n'arrivais pas à le voir donc on se dit
bon briques de l'über ses 79 172 autres
aux états unis vrai
ça a été décrit depuis soixante dix mois
oui nous allons tour mais c'est qui ce
truc mais si l'on continue à former des
économistes ils sont ils sont au courant
de sa serrure soit ils sont pas au
courant soit six ans courant justement
il dit c'est pas important puisque avec
les lunettes de la croissance c'est un
fait qui rendent pas ça rentre pas dans
les équations ça rentre pas dans ce
schéma mental ça rende pas dans et puis
ça ça
ça annonce peut-être la fin de définitif
de la croissance mondiale ça ne marche
pas ça colle pas donc il faut renoncer à
ses croyances à ces histoires à tout ce
qui a fait notre carrière si c'est un
scientifique qui a déjà voilà qui a déjà
d un poste qui a déjà des publications
renoncer à tout ça c'est difficile donc
on est pris dans des schémas mais ça
c'est harry avec sapiens qui le dit bien
aussi on est pris dans nos croyances nos
histoires nos mythologies et on préfère
on préfère
renoncer au fait que renoncer à nos
croyances il y avait une secte là dessus
dans les années 50 mais c'est les
psychologues qui sache ça depuis
longtemps les années 50 60 alors je me
souviens plus mais on en parle dans le
bouquin dans comment tout peut
s'effondrer la
queue
et le gourou disait assez à ses adeptes
bon on va prier prier parce que c'est
plus ont pris plus on veut enfin alors
l'échangé de sauver parce que des
extraterrestres vont venir et vont nous
sauver
et puis je vois j'ai vu comment ça
s'appelait mais je suis tombé quand même
un gros effondrements je connais pas les
témoins de jéhovah mais c'est possible
il ya plein de sectes millénaristes that
un ami imaginaire tuque rendu
je crois pas en dieu en tant qu'ami
alors j'ai découvert il n'y a pas
longtemps que j'étais plutôt spinosi
c'est à dire une sorte de voie la nature
avec un grand n c'est ça qu'ils
considéraient comme dieu ça me parle
après je sais pas j'ai
va dire ça mais ça fait un peu intello
je serais pas là je ne veux pas l'église
tu veux pas la mousse qu'ils jouent pas
la synagogue non je pratique jeu
pratiquement type hors jeu pratiqué
l'athéisme plus tôt pendant des années
là je pratique plus je suis plutôt assez
intéressé par plutôt maintenant par
l'histoire des religions par tout ça ça
me ça me touche juste pachamama quoi
ouais ouais il ya des trucs vachement
intéressant là dedans mais un peu dans
tout en fait comme j'avais une et j'ai
une éducation catholique en fait
j'ai fait ma communion tout ça j'allais
au catéchisme et ça m'intéressait pas
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas absorber beaucoup
je trouve que tu m'intéresses
m'intéressait pas à ça quand j'étais
petit j'étais plutôt braqués sur les
animaux et fourmies la science tout ça
on commence alors faire saigner les
oreilles ou pas quand tu veux
alors un petit effondrement commencent à
se mobilisent
comment ça se modélise
et ben
[Musique]
commence à se modélise
grosse question
le modèle que c'est intéressant pour
commencer ses modèles au club de rome on
en a parlé
le rapport au club de rome par dix le
modèle world 3 ça c'était dans les
années soixante dix la nes om haïti
naissance des premiers ordinateurs et
puis tu as un prof qui s'appelle jay
forrester est reçue qui a inventé la
mémoire ram il a fait la dynamique des
systèmes voilà il agrée une discipline
où il crée des systèmes avec un groupe
plein de boucles de rétroaction
et puis là il met ses étudiants dont
dennis meadows et sert à toute une
équipe sur le modèle world 3 donc ils
ont modélisé le monde avec
croissance croissance économique
industrie
population taux de natalité taux de
mortalité tout ça voilà c'est assez
complexe pourtant c'est un modèle
simplifié du monde et parce qu'il ya pas
le climat enfin il manque plein de
choses en fait voilà et puis ils ont mis
les chiffres réels ils ont appuyé sur
enter et ils ont vu comment le modèle a
évolué pendant 150 ans 1re modélisation
du monde et puis non qu'ils appuient sur
inter et l'effondrement des courbes
goûtant première moitié du xxième siècle
qui s'était encore années 70 voilà il
fonde remet entre jeu pas 2020 2015 et
2050 donc toutes les courbes partent en
exponentiel et un moment je s'effondre
ils seront
gérés bien aimé voir leur tête
d'ailleurs il faut qu'on fait il
faudrait faire quelque chose là dessus
mais et
du coup ils se disent bon bah on a un
modèle informatique
on va bouger les paramètres on va
trouver des solutions ok alors il ya le
modèle population bon bah on va faire du
planning familial tout ça on va réduire
la natalité
diminué l'expo n'en ciel de la
population ok ils bougent lessive c'est
parfait c'est super l'informatique enter
effondrement et puis non non on va
doubler les rendements agricoles maya
bonne idée hop fois de enter
effondrement
et puis on va
faire des technologies efficientes on va
d polluée on va moins consommer
d'énergies non renouvelables et plein de
solutions et à chaque fois enter
effondrement parfois ils fondremand
encore plus brutale et plus rapide et du
coup un moment je crois que c'était aux
11e 12e scénario chez plus ils font
toutes les solutions en même temps enter
et hop ça se stabilise ouf donc là il
publie le rapport il y avait
effectivement une trajectoire selon le
modèle de war iii où tous les paramètres
de la civilisation de la société du
système monde
se stabilise dans ce que il appellerait
les anglais le steady state économie le
tout développement durable un plateau
développement durable c est l expression
des années 80
comment dire en français enfin voilà en
tout cas l'idée c'était dans les années
70 on pouvait
entrevoir la possibilité
de stabiliser
notre notre société en accord avec la
russie
wen au style de vie en accord avec la
biosphère et vais pas encore trop
d'inégalités encore cukor avec le pays
contre guillemets tiers-mondiste alors
ça c'est justement ce n'était pas dans
le modèle il n'y avait pas les
inégalités sociales enfin il faudrait
complexifier le modèle à fond mais c'est
vrai que c'est un paramètre qui joue
beaucoup dans les les inégalités dans
l'accélération des effondrements
d'ailleurs c'est un modèle qu'on a
décrit dans le livre et c'est paru juste
avant d'ailleurs quand on était en train
d'écrire en 2014
le modèle en 10 h à rdi avec qui a fait
pas mal de bruit à l'époque parce qu'il
était co financée par la nasa et du coup
les journalistes il avait il avait fait
le buzz en dix ans la nasa n'en annonce
la fin du monde
en gros c'était un modèle mathématique
basé sur prédateur froid un truc très
simple au niveau équations
différentielles et ça disait en gros
qu'il avait fait plusieurs scénarios que
plus une société est avait des
inégalités sociales économiques plus
elle s'effondrait radicalement
brutalement et de manière irréversible
pourquoi que ce que tu entends parler
fonderont c'est quoi
dans ce cas là c'est
enfin la définition des archéologues
c'est une diminution brutale de la
population dans une zone donnée dans une
région donnée
ça c'est une définition qui est pas mal
quand on regarde a posteriori quand on
regarde le cas de la civilisation
romaine maya etc par contre pour nous
c'est un peu délicat
si on dit et c'est une possibilité qu'un
effondrement global a déjà commencé
maintenant aujourd'hui
parler en termes de population voilà
c'est cette définition n'est pas
terrible du coup nous on a utilisé la
définition de qu'avait proposé yves
cochet qui est le processus à l'issue
duquel les besoins de base de la
population se chauffer se nourrir se
déplacer ne sont plus fournies par des
services encadré par la loi et de
manière durable donc là c'est une
définition voilà un peu plus discutable
mais plus tangible pour pour discuter
d'effondrement aujourd'hui pour les
générations présentes c'est pour ça que
le sous titre le livre c'est toujours
quoi ces genres banlieue 13 la route
c'est toujours cool bon alors ça c'est
ouais mad max il ya guérilla de bertone
il ya plein de roman post apocalyptique
plaint d' imaginaires qui qui émerge du
coup quand on parle d'effondrement nous
on a choisi le mot effondrement pour ça
justement pour faire péter l'imaginaire
pour mettre les pieds dans le plat pour
éviter que ce soit récupérer parce que
moi j'avais pendant des années utiliser
le mot transition depuis 2009 2010
transition la stratégie de mots
transition c'est d'être neutre justement
c'est un mot gentil c'est un mot neutre
qui ne cliff pas et du coup qui est
inclusif c'est-à-dire qui prend tous les
courants toutes les étiquettes et on est
tous dans le même bateau et on va faire
une grande transition c'est à dire qu'on
va tous fut b ça va être bien se passer
c'est vrai qu'il ya un côté positif mais
ça fait du bien c'est un côté positif
c'est un côté bisous ce que tu veux ça
dépend de ta culture
alors beaucoup de gens traitent salah de
bisounours j'ai un arc en ciel sur le
foot on this shows
et pourquoi pas assez ok c'est très
positif j'ai remarqué que ça fait
sahamies prix enfin comment dire ça
ça a provoqué des prises de conscience
quand même j'ai beaucoup de gens qui
enfin dans tous les milieux donc à
politiser politisés de gauche de droite
des yeux des jeunes beaucoup de femmes
aussi parce que dans les milieux enfin
politisé il y avait beaucoup d'hommes le
coup là j'ai vu le public changer en
fait c'était à liège essayer c'est un
terreau associatif très militant très de
gauche très
ouvriers à liège et du coup on s'est mis
sur la transition et le public a changé
c'est vrai que ça a fait quelque chose
et puis il ya des écueils fait un plan
nous parler si tu venais c'est
sa stratégie commence à une image
apolitique et c'est voulu
par contre ils ont un discours clair sur
le pic pétrolier sur les catastrophes
c'est lucide mais c'est apolitique mais
c'est une stratégie parce qu'en fait
c'est très politique le mouvement
d'étrangers de des villes en transition
c'est se réapproprier
la politique municipale faire les choses
concrètement avancer enfin c'est se
réapproprier la politique municipale
c'est pas un pansement sur une jambe de
bois quand tu vois l'inertie de notre
société parce qu'on les voit bien les
gars qui font des petits potagers dans
paris là où les chiens font pipi
parterre où il met des petits choux ils
font des petits bacs à fleurs ils se
font des bisous le dimanche quand leurs
graines mais a dû caricature mélange
l'avocat du diable il ya il ya bien il
faut deux mètres carré de potager en
super culture améliorer façon 1 k
pour soutenir une famille de six
personnes non mais c'est pas ça la
question le truc c'est que ces questions
ouais non mais on peut discuter de ça il
ya des secours est carrément je sais pas
les mètres carrés mais il ya plein enfin
c'est critiquable parce que les potagers
sous les toits fin il ya des fermes
urbaines du rjr à technologie qui
utilise électricité des métaux voilà du
verre etc tout est critiquable mais il
ya il ya comme je disais ça prend des
années de de fait de se rendre compte de
ça et on y va graduellement se situait à
quelqu'un qui découvre tu lui dis tout
lui balance tout ça le casse moi j'ai
déjà cassé des publics au début j'étais
enthousiaste j'ai fait un cours de 4
heures j'ai balancé tous les graphiques
sur le climat et où il était démontée
ils n'étaient pas équipés pour
comprendre mais c'est pareil ils étaient
pas et qui bon vous voyez à la manière
de le dire il ya ce qu'on dit il faut
s'adapter au public et du coup toutes
ces petites initiatives qui ont l'air
gentille parce que peut-être ça fait des
années qu'on est là dedans parce qu'on
voit peut-être d'autres facettes on a
d'autres cultures etc
ça peut paraître dérisoire mais ça fait
du bien aux gens ça allait mais dans
l'action et puis ils se rendent compte
après quelques mois que c'est pas assez
j'ai eu beaucoup de gens qui m'ont dit
[__] c'est quoi ce potager ça va pas
nourrir ma famille mais en même temps
quoi ils ont fait du lien dans le
quartier ils ont développé un lien ou
pas avec eux les élus du coup ils ont
obtenu ça ils ont obtenu un financement
ils se sont bougés ça les a motivés et
ça leur a permis par exemple de quitter
leur boulot de se dire belge fait une
formation en traction animale et puis on
y va petit à petit il faut enfin je
pense faut pas trop juger je ne juge pas
je me fais même plus doux l'armée ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont tendance à
juger juger ben justement le côté pense
comptent sur une jambe de bois bah ouais
et puis de l'autre côté c'est des
caricatures ya les survivalistes et
voilà les bisounours
gallet bisounours est surréaliste et
puis chacun sait les bisounours thouars
ça secoue les éclaire au milieu du tee
shirts et ça
et voilà et dans le mouvement la
transition on caricature les
survivalistes et moi je les très bons
conducteurs qui est toujours là parce
que parce qu'on les connaît pas parce
que pourquoi tu as peut-être pas cherché
à vue à les connaître alors au début non
parce que justement c'était parce qu'on
est pris dans notre culture etc on est
on n'a pas le temps d'aller voir on se
dit bon on regarde les documentaires
dans national geographic des trucs
américain en quarts c'est qu'il a
toujours eu un amour se donne la mort
c'est pas notre culture
c'est les états unis et puis on se rend
compte que en europe 1 il ya des gens
qui se préparent aussi alors on va sur
les forums ça commence à faire peur et
puis a des idées on n'est pas d'accord
du coup on se fait voilà c'est une
nébuleuse on cherche pas à comprendre et
ça fait du bien de caricaturer l'autre
parce que comme ça ça renforce nos
positions et ses classiques alors ce
soit on va caricaturer personnes on nous
nous on s'est permis de vous étudiez
vous d'étudier les survivalistes
d'étudier tout tous ces gens qui
gravitent autour de cette problématique
et on va échanger autour de ces de ce
genre là les survivalistes yale
survivalistes de base et elle surgit la
liste de la hopper classe qui investit
dans un bunker super high tech où le
prix du bunker au mètre carré a explosé
tu les a suivis sous là je n'ai pas
rencontré nan j'ai vu le fameux article
du new yorker qui a été traduit dans
mediapart a le crieur qui a fait
beaucoup de bruit
il ya eu les mêmes qui achètent en
argentine d'ailleurs qui sait mais il ya
beaucoup de gars qui vont acheter du
terrain en argent et en nouvelle-zélande
la densité de population kilomètres
carrés très faible où ils sont livrés
tout ce qu'il filme un vrai il ya des
super riches qui étudie les zones du
monde et puis ce tableau il ya pas de
centrales nucléaires là où il ya un
potager ils ont une piste d'avion direct
pour l'heure leur ferme avait en
autonomie yay leur bunker lors tout ce
que tu veux il ya des glisses le jour
bilis leurs milices en fait il y passe
que ce qu'est ce que montre et
l'arctique c'est que en fait ils
flippent que ils savent ils se rendent
compte certains quand on dit il infecte
ivement il ya de toi y en a qui savent
pas y en ait qui veulent pas savoir y en
avait qui se croit pas il y en a qui se
prépare et qui savent très bien à davos
en 2000 je crois que c'était 2014 2013
faudrait revoir le thème de davos du
forum économique mondial c'était la
résilience on parlait de tous les
risques enfin voilà donc c'est un
système qui parle de résilience dans le
sens pour ceux
pour ce faire télécharger une sonnerie
ça je sais pas mais pour se perpétuer
pour pour maintenir un système donc il
ya deux faces de la résilience faut voir
le mouvement de la transition il utilise
ses la résilience des sociétés locales
les communautés pour pas mourir pour pas
crever la gueule ouverte alors que à
davos c'est la résidence pour maintenir
un système économique inique dégueulasse
et c'est donc voilà il faut se méfier il
ya de tout mais il ya des super riches
effectivement qu'ils savent très bien
ils sont très bien informés c'est ce que
disait chomsky d'ailleurs aucun nom
n'est cité avant peut-être qu'ils ont lu
d'ailleurs mais il ya plein de bouquins
je lisais quelque part mais qui
s'appelle michael ruppert ouais super il
m'a aussi influencé au début car je
connais pas personnellement mais ces
bouquets des témoins le documentaire du
club ce nom collapse ça m'avait
bouleversé l'époque oui mais voilà aux
états unis il y avait un chiffre il
faudrait aussi vérifier mes douze mille
titres de livres sur le survivalisme pas
douze mille livres 12 mille titres
différents c'est une véritable culture
ses fins et voilà il ya beaucoup donc
forcément on est un moment on est au
courant il suffit d'arriver à y croire
toute l'info est là et quand on a ce
déclic imagine tu as des millions
surtout compte en banque
tu as une famille tu commences à te
renseigner et à des potes un peu
scientifiques chercheurs ont tenu bon
dans l'enseignement si tu veux tu as ta
des moyens premier réflexe tu dis bon je
m'achetais une cabane dans le montana
petits trucs à la walden voilà ça donne
à qui dit coûte cette casse les couilles
parce que il y aura culturellement rien
pour survivre donc laisse tomber tu as
ta cabane ya pas de musée tu comprends
voilà et si tu as une culture je
n'essaie pas de la peur une culture de
la technologie culture tu as vu plein de
films post apocalyptique tu travailles
silicon valley et ses bâtons ton truc ça
va être plutôt un bunker en nouvelle
zélande n'est ce pas moi ça dépend des
cultures et plein de gens se préparent
mais s'est longtemps dit plan b sur
quatre fois le tour du monde je suis sûr
qu'il y en a qui font ça en fait ce que
j'ai découvert c'est que quand on dit
les survivalistes c'est vraiment tout un
éventail pareil la transition c'est tout
un éventail et en creusant parce que du
coup nous notre cheval de bataille je
dirais c'est d'aller complexifier les
choses on pose le mot effondrement on va
voir ce qu'il ya derrière survivalistes
c'est quoi on va essayer de voir
derrière donc ces partis nos futures
recherches même si au début on a
caricaturé
et c'est donc transit
survivalistes et bien il ya de tout
aussi il ya
des gens d'ailleurs qu'ils veulent plus
appeler survivalistes parce que ça a
était connotée ici un peu extrême droite
et du coup forcément vous quand même bah
ouais certains beaucoup d'hommages du
coup est en france on a tendance des cas
étiquette extrême droite on balaye on
bloque l'accès à certains médias et
skhira champeymont stupide de hanche
mouais enfin moi je trouve aussi parce
que faut aller voir aussi ce cas
derrière
mes cd phénomène typique ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à bisounours puis
on balaye d'un revers de main tu
survivalistes on balaye pédophiles on
balaye franchissez liste donc baleine
mais non mais il ya des étiquettes une
fois que tu les as tu es foutu avis
c'est fait à dessein de temps en temps
dans oui / non du coup survivalistes
voilà c'était aujourd'hui c'est connoté
extrême droite alors c'est marrant parce
que dans les années 70 il y avait des
survivalistes il y avait tout ce
mouvement des revues la gueule ouverte
survivaient vivre le mouvement
écologiste néo c'est radical alors y est
le parti qui est née puis à les radicaux
enfin les les écolos dur quoi qui se
préparait à la à l'apocalypse nucléaire
etc il était c'était des survivalistes
mais plutôt gauche extrême gauche il
était dans l'autonomie le partage le
larzac enfin le retour à la terre et
aujourd'hui c'est paradoxal c'est plutôt
l'extrême droite mais il ya des gens
justement qu'ils veulent qu'ils font des
retours comment dire des des stages
2010 de saut de retour à la vie sauvage
d'immersion de survie de survie douce il
ya plein de termes comme ça meiway aller
manger les plantes sauvages et tout
refaire un tu vois faire du feu
apprendre à vivre dans la forêt mais moi
je trouve ça c'est passionnant tout ça
enfin c'est c'est pas à balayer d'un
revers de main donc c'est tout à fait on
va on va prendre ce qu'ils sont un peu
moins bisounours qui se balade entre ea
qui mettent des rangers ce qu'ils savent
on va dire survivre dans des milieux
hostiles et en terrain hostile est ce
que tu as fait une prospective sur
l'armée est ce que tu t'es un peu
intéressés on va prendre notre âme et
française ensuite peut-être l'armée
européenne et puis ensuite différentes
armées comme les etats unis aussi est-ce
que tu surveilles est-ce que tu veilles
sur leurs méthodes d'organisation
non je vais y pas j'ai été effectivement
en contact avec
une personne à l'armée belge
qui mariage belge l'armée suisse et
l'armée française
quel grade quel poste sais pas
qu'est ce que tu appelles être mis en
relation je suis à creuser autour d'une
belle anna
cc1 c'est un ami je savais pas qu'il ya
un ancien parent ami d'il ya vingt ans
et on s'est perdus de vue on s'est revu
récemment et puis il avait fait l'armée
il avait arrêté ce qui faisait voilà et
du coup il m'a raconté toute sa vie et
puis en fait on s'est revus par ce que
il a découvert par ses études d'officier
à l'armée le premier pic pétrolier que
l'armée n'était pas du tout préparé ce
style belge en belgique c'est pas du
tout une culture de la préparation et du
coup lui là il a fait un gros travail
justement de sur ces sujets pour amener
ce sujet en fait à l'armée et c'est
assez passionnant et du coup yann alors
le suis je me souviens plus mais j'ai
découvert que l'armée suisse était brave
et une culture comme les suisses de la
puce de la préparation
non seulement chacun chez soi un bunker
à une armes et caetera et
potentiellement soldats c'est une armée
de milice jamais suivi le
l'exercice suisse qui s'appelle stop
bilou douille avec des milliers de
blocage des frontières ouais ouais si si
mais ils ont fait un exercice blocage
des effondrements d'italie blocage des
frontières effondrement de la france ils
ont fait une simulation aussi y avait
chez page fument aussi deux voilà de
réfugiés donc 6000 suisse qui étaient
mobilisés pour cet exercice grandeur
nature
c'est le
2000-2006 faire aller allons-y mais en
belgique c'est très intéressant parce
qu'il n'a pas du tout cette culture de
la préparation et la belgique c'est un
pays plat sur lesquelles toutes les
armées passe et c'est un lieu de passage
en fait l'armée n'est pas du tout formés
pour bloquer pour garder un pays c'est
pas ça le rôle du coup il n'y a pas
cette culture est en france c'est un peu
différent c'est beaucoup plus opaque et
moi j'étais en juste en relation avec
des chercheurs
de saint cyr donc c'était pas du tout
l'armée chercheur de quoi cherche à les
trouver c'était cherchant ses des
chercheurs sur le la géopolitique fin le
chercheur mais je suis pas allé les voir
on sait on s'est vus à 17 ans fin on
s'est parlé à distance
donc
j'ai bas j'ai moins d'infos sur l'âme et
française mais j'aimerais bien en avoir
en fait ce qui m'intéresse c'est plutôt
d'aller voir comprendre comment il
fonctionne comment l'armée peut
éventuellement se préparer ou trois ans
c'est un faux ou pas parce que moi
j'avais terrain on avait été influencé
dans le livre par des rapports de
l'armée allemande
étasunienne australienne sur le pic
pétrolier donc il décrivait très bien
les conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
l'armée allemande s'était fondremand si
le pic pétrolier a lieu en 2010 et il a
lieu le brut a eu en 2006 2007 l'armée
prévoyait un effondrement
de nos sociétés
2025 2030
la bundeswehr l'armée allemande voilà
donc c'est des possibilités mais ça fait
quand même réfléchir et l'armée
étasunienne y avait eu sur le pic
pétrolier et plusieurs rapports
l'administration ont fait le rapport
hirsch qui est passionnant 2005 et sur
le pétrole ça il faut aller lire c'est
fou 2005 on savait déjà tout puis après
on se tape huit ans de bush enfin c'est
terrible c'est terrible et il ya eu pas
mal de rapport aux états unis s'est mis
en ligne c'est avec les fous sur le
climat le rapport entre larmes et le
climat et le les possibilités de
géopolitique de déstabilisation que
c'est effrayant enfin c'est vraiment fou
quoi
enfin tous les scénarios voilà scénario
plus de degrés il appelle sa
catastrophique il faut un scénario plus
9 degrés de moyenne scénario
anéantissement il appelle avec voile à
+2° guerre nucléaire entre pas qui
pakistan et 1,2 pour les ressources en
eau pour enfin c'est fou moi j'ai eu
phréatiques la borne hommes ce
catastrophique la nappe phréatique ouais
j'ai pas trop d'infos là dessus mais
c'est vrai qu'elle est la fonte
justement des glaciers de l'himalaya est
la diminution de l'eau potable lassé
dramatique surtout qu'au bangladesh
montée des eaux du coup ça s'apprend en
étau des milliers des centaines de
millions de personnes et en plus avec
les tensions ethniques etc ils sont en
train de construire un mur je paye
combien de kilomètres de long entre les
deux
voilà il ya un climatologue
du bangladesh où ils sont ça me revient
pas mais sans le bouquin qui parle de
génocide climatique de l'expression
voilà et l'armée le boulot de l'armée
c'est quoi mais c'est de prévoir les
mauvaises nouvelles forcément ils sont
lucides là dessus on peut ne pas les
croire le gouvernement peut ne pas
croire les corps de l'armée qui font de
la recherche là dessus mais je pense que
c'est le boulot de l'armée d'être de
prévoir ça c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant d'aller voir ce que fait
l'armée après dans la recherche j'ai pas
accès du tout
ah bah enfin ou comme un moment où je
suis pas comme on dit à ce cadrage
décision à tout ça je sais pas atteint
quitte pas après ils vont appeler cette
émission
je suis en train de jeter un coup d'oeil
aux questions ok tu
vois personnellement tu t'es entre les
deux entre survivalistes ou bisounours
tu as des boîtes de conserve son lit
d'un décalage qui est bien planqué d'un
plan b pour pas de faire série sur
l'autoroute si par exemple les banques
ton du jour au lendemain et que rungis
n'est pas approvisionnée tu as prévu
d'utiliser les routes secondaires
tu as un réseau local d'amis j'ai dit à
bruxelles
g
ouais j'avoue que je suis entre les deux
c'est interdit non
enfin j'ai des couteaux une carabine à
plombs en fait ouais mais vous peut-être
un jour ouais enfin là je suis partie à
la campagne il ya beaucoup de chasseurs
donc ça fait partie de la culture locale
donc c'est vrai que ça m'attire bien
d'aller connaître justement le les gens
du village tout le monde la culture
locale donc
à la base ça m'attirait pas trop la
chasse mais c'est vrai que
je ne m'empêche pas d'aller voir et
d'aller participer parce que je pense
qu'il faut il faut vivre avec ses
voisins il faut être bien implanté dans
la culture locale
ça ça arrivait pas quand j'étais en
ville on a vécu longtemps à bruxelles
j'aurais pu eu l'idée d'aller chasser
mais voilà dans c'est pour dire que j'ai
découvert récemment
je pense qu'on a tous un survivalistes
en nous en fait qu'ils s'expriment plus
ou moins qu'on peut voilà qui et c'est
normal c'est une sorte de besoin de
sécurité quand on a une famille quand on
commence à se faire des délires sur des
scénarios instinct de conservation chez
pablo c'est quoi moi je suis plutôt
plutôt dans l'organisation
gérer les jeux c'est pas le quartier les
voisins
même je serais plutôt pour aller voir on
est dans un petit village donc le
conseil municipal comment s'organise
tout ça je suis pas trop dans les
scénarios
où des hordes de ce que tu es sur la
femme et viennent nous dévorer nous nous
égorger tous à ce culte chez lui du
stuff les boues sur la psychologie des
foules ouais moi je comprends je suis
pas trop sur l'irrationalité des foules
donc l'idée c'était que l'être humain
seul il est rationnel et peut être
rationnel mais dès qu'il est en foule
c'est irrationnel alors il peut y avoir
des mouvements irrationnels de foule
mais je pense qu'il a trop exagérer le
trait
je pense que j'ai vu des gens que je
t'ai du nutella toi
maintenant mais il ya des mouvements de
foule mais c'est des cas particuliers
l'exemple d'une telle à je pense qu'il
est il est par l'ansés 1 il ya des gros
billets là dedans raconte
[Musique]
déjà enfin c'est pas passé partout cd cd
des points chauds puis c'est tout les
caméras qui arrive batel magasin il ya
eu des camions s'était démarqué et du
coup on a quelques images et puis ça
fait le tour du monde et on généralise
quelque chose qui arrivait avec black
friday
bb c'est pareil c'est pareil on a peu
d'endroits et puis des images peu
d'image qui tourne en boucle donc il ya
un billet déjà je suis catherine on n'a
pas montré voilà non mais justement
catherine avec un de choses à dire on
n'a pas montré tous les gens qui sont
pas allés au black friday voilà en fait
c'est une mise en scène nutella ou black
friday
de tous nos penchants
c'est un exutoire de tous nos penchants
de consommation c'est un peu comme un
carnaval carnaval on un jour de l'année
on se lâche complètement on se travestit
en se déguisant en ce qu'on aime pas
faim voilà c'est un exutoire sociale et
ça je pense que c'est ça canalise un
exutoire de cette société de
consommation mais c'est pas du tout
représentatif de l'être humain pas du
tout et par contre c'est représentatif
d'une culture de l'égoïsme qu'on a
développés qui s'est installée des
quelques décennies et qui est très
implantée mais une culture de l'égoïsme
c'est ça veut dire que ça veut pas dire
la nature humaine est mauvaise et en
fait nous l'être humain moderne libéral
depuis 400 ans depuis descartes qui
s'est détaché de la nature qui se pense
en dehors de la nature cette scission 7
cette coupure métaphysique elle est
super violente et là on la vit parce que
dès qu'on voit des images d'êtres
humains
qui ceux qui se sont violents entre eux
voilà on en déduit la nature humaine est
mauvaise parce qu'on n'a aucune idée de
ce qui se passe dans la nature et c'est
l'objet de notre livre l'entr'aide le
club la jungle qui est sorti là il ya
quelques mois pour lesquels j'ai tourné
en ce moment on a écrit avec gauthier
chapelle qui errent biologiste et on est
allé voir dans la dans la nature ce qui
se passe il ya énormément d'entre elles
toutes les espèces toutes les espèces
sont ont des relations mutuellement
bénéfiques avec d'autres espèces
sous-espèces sauvage tout d'accord allez
on va bien sûr les ans mais sur du bon
élevage l'aco et voler si tu connais tu
connais le proverbe qui dit quand il
n'est plus de foin dans les râteliers
les chevaux se bat
tu le connais celui là non je
connaissais pas mais ça mais c'est du
bon terroir bien de chez nous cdo
bourgogne quand il ya plus d'une fois
dans les râteliers les chevaux se bat
si demain je te mets dans le cas de
figure
puis d'approvisionnement de rungis
selon deux paramètres grève ou selon de
paramètres climat où selon paramètres
attentats
où selon eux par là on pourrait
continuer longtemps sur le paramètre
donc trêve doit dire grève de la chaîne
alimentaire aux ruptures de l'achat
liban à harissa en est mal enfin paris
les taxis ils ont décidé d'arrêter de
faire chier le monde
aux aéroports ils ont décidé d'être un
peu plus joueur intelligent il se met
devant régis bon là telle armée qui
démarque il ya eu le cas en
grande-bretagne en 2150 grévistes des
camionneurs qui transportait du pétrole
150 qui font la grève au bout de cinq
six jours l'armée était prête à
intervenir donc le pétrole qui vous cite
la cage orly donc c'est des jouets non
mais c'est c'est grave parce qu'il ya eu
des opérations annuler des opérations
chirurgicales
il ya eu des des entreprises qui ont
fait faillite comparé redémarrer en cas
les écoles fermées voilà en trois quatre
jours en fait c'est une crise cardiaque
de la société et crise cardiaque chaque
chaque seconde chaque minute qui passe
situerait à nîmes pas tu risques de ne
plus pouvoir revenir à l'état normal
état initial et nous on peut on a
tellement interconnecté homogénéiser
tout avec des chaînes
d'approvisionnement en flux tendu avec
des désordres main que la crise
cardiaque on peut plus se permettre
deux trois quatre jours ce une semaine
c'est dramatique une semaine de black
out c'est la folie alors qu'avant nos
grands parents il avait deux mois mais
c'était normal d'avoir deux mois de
nourriture chez soi soucis sont c'était
c'était normal
mais dire maintenant aujourd'hui on ne
prend pour un survivalistes parce que tu
as deux mois de stock chez toi c'est fou
donc on a une culture bon de de
l'hétéronomie c'est à dire qu on est le
contraire d'autonomes on est devenus
hétéronome dépendant d'un système qui
nous nourrit au jour le jour en flux
tendu c'est hyper fragile hyper
vulnérables bon rares gisp est ce bloc
c'est pareil en deux trois jours c'est
la panique alors pourquoi ça peut être
la panique a tancé la panique ça dépend
laissez-la que c'est intéressant dans
certains points il peut y avoir des
tensions donc l'effet nutella on va
l'appeler ok parce que tu as une culture
de l'égoïsme ça veut pas dire que la
nature humaine est comme ça ça veut dire
qu'on a appris à être comme ça mais ça
on le montre bien dans notre livre sur
l'entrée
nous ce qu'on montre c'est que c'est
c'est pas les pénuries le problème
c'est les pénuries à venir en fait
l'être humain il sait gérer les pénuries
depuis des centaines de milliers
d'années on a été fait l'être on a été
j'en ai évolué là dessus ce qui est
dangereux c'est d'arriver dans les
pénuries avec une culture de l'égoïsme
en croyant que l'autre il va te bouffer
la gueule et c'est ça la boucle tu vois
il ya un paradoxe temporel
philosophiques métaphysiques d'ailleurs
que que les mails bien jean-pierre dupuy
s'est il ya une prophétie
auto-réalisatrice si tu crois si tu es
dans le bain culturel que ton voisin des
capus nourriture il va venir te voler tu
peux que te préparer à ça et en te
prépares ans en croyant ça les hautes
voix et y est du coup ils croient et ça
fait un sacré les conditions que tu
voulais justement éviter quand on va
rester très terre-à-terre on va pas dire
voilà par mimétisme montbazens prépare
moi aussi je me prépare parce que quand
extrapole ce sujet là ça donne la guerre
froide et tout un droit
là on va parler simplement d'apport
calorifique d'accord
quant à une catastrophe naturelle ou
quentin on va dire imaginons un attentat
salle avec quatre canettes de matières
fissiles qui explose là où il ya de
l'alimentation de la flotte ou des
choses comme ça
on s'est rendu compte par exemple à
katrina qu au bout de 48 heures
les gens
même les plus gentils quand on se posait
des questions
aller dans la rue des rapines chat
katrina 2005 à la nouvelle orléans ou
même à samart ont récemment ben
justement en fait on a on a creusé la
question et puis y'a pas mal
d'études qui sont parus là dessus on a
fait la compil donc c'est jacques
leconte le psychologue qui a écrit un
livre qui s'appelle la bonté humaine qui
nous a pas mal influencé nos amis sur la
voie c'était pas en 2010 chez odile
jacob et puis lui il a fait une compil
aussi de les psychologues des
sociologues qui ont étudié les
témoignages des rescapés des
catastrophes et du coup il ya un livre
génial aussi en anglais tant il faudrait
absolument le traduire c'est de rebecca
sol dit la paradise built in elle
commence toujours montre comment les
communautés font face au désastre il ya
un chapitre sur le nouvelle orléans
katrina est en fait qui montre c'est que
dans toutes les catastrophes tsunami les
catastrophes brutale thoune a mis
attaque terroriste crash d'avion
incendie tremblement de terre et c'est
le comportement majoritaire mais ultra
majoritaire celle entraide et
l'auto-organisation
plus on va à l'épicentre plus il ya du
silence pas du tout de panique de l'auto
organisation et d acte d'altruisme
extrêmes
les tours jumelles pareil les
témoignages ces épiphénomènes ah non non
non non les ai trouvés massif il est ici
anti vie qu'on m'aime abandonné le terme
de panique alors ce qui se passe
pourquoi on l'attend mais c'est normal
parce que quand on est choqué quand tu
vois tout ton environnement voilà tu
cherches la sécurité tu cherche d'abord
à aider l'autre
ça c'est sûr le moment là où peut
arriver la culture là où où la culture
de l'égoïsme est toxique c'est un moment
quand voilà quand ça retombe et puis
quand l'entr'aide qui était magnifique
tu vois il ya des dents les survivants
il ya des gens qui les voisins ils
trouvent une casserole ils se font à
manger et survivre quoi
l'être humain il est comme ça
fondamentalement après l'entr'aide peut
se dégrader et ça c'est passionnant ce
qu'on monte dans le bouquin sur
l'entr'aide c'est que l'entraidé
puissante mais elle est aussi fragile et
dans un groupe il suffit que tu es un
tricheur de tricheurs ou des milices des
économistes des passagers clandestins
pour que les autres coopérer et tout ça
ils se disent m élites riches [__] lui
la volée verbaux moi j'arrête de
coopérer j'arrête de participer au bien
commun et la lente raid s'effondre mais
comme une traînée de poudre et là tu
reviennes à la structure de l'égoïsme
qui revient pourtant les banques elle
triche
alors mais justement il ya plessis qui
triche jamais ya des 10 économies
passionnant option est riche barça c'est
toxique pour la société on est dans des
sociétés ultra coopérative d'accord de
millions d'individus c'est unique dans
l'espèce dans milliards milliards ainsi
ouais si tu élargi c'est unique dans le
monde animal c'est unique on est une
société une espèce ultra sociale m
humain c'est fou même entre personnes
anonymes qui se connaissent pas qu'on
rien à voir génétiquement entre eux
c'est fou et on arrive à faire c'est
cette cohésion à cause de la culture on
est des sociétés ultra coopérative grâce
à deux sculptures bain les coopératives
les syndicats l'école internet tout ça
c'est des incroyables
outils collaboratifs et du vernis
complètement vient d'annoncer la base
garde on est huit à une pointure de
l'égoïsme qui vient tu as des banquiers
et puis ça s'installe peu à peu ça
grignote ça ronge et puis ça ça peut
faire renverser tu voyais à la et puis
un seuil à partir duquel sa peux tu te
trouves pas que ces désagréments du
vernis regardes tu parles d'une société
qui coopèrent
on va élargir à au monde
n'y a pas de guerre
je parle pas d'un manque bisounours
d'accord dans les bars on parle du neuf
on vraiment d'une société thermo
industriels y a pas que la france
l'europe la suisse et la belgique
6 6 le dollar se vautre que les
africains restent plus acheter à manger
jeudi d afrique et entre guillemets les
pays pauvres en face de la ceinture
méditerranéenne est ce que tu crois que
les suisses ils vont les accueillir à
bras ouverts quand on voit le danemark
j'ai été récemment au danemark il vole
pas de mire au danemark 1 vole pas est
ce que tu trouves ton coopèrent beaucoup
c'est simplement du bullshit qu'on nous
raconte à longueur de journée que les
sociétés coopèrent que les gens
coopèrent et que sais tu ce vernis n'est
que maintenu par de la dette
et par on est tout gentil ça va bien se
passer
si tu fermes un petit robinet tu crois
que ça va rester aussi gentil que ça non
mais dans ce cas là oui il ya du vernis
il ya enfin entre les pays c'est plus
compliqué que ça lorsqu'on entre dans la
nature il ya aussi des actes d'agression
en compétition enfin il faut vous il
s'agit pas de le nier tu vois le le lion
il mange la gachère pas et se tabassent
pas entre clans pour avoir accès à la
base mais l'afflux main il tue son
prochain tranquillement ça fait depuis
la nuit des temps
les orques
enfin voila
mais on peut pas nier tout le reste de
l'autre côté du tableau les lionnes elle
coopère pour chasser tout où vit en
symbiose faire un pote des micro
organismes en symbiose dans toi il
pourrait pas vivre sans toi d'ailleurs
c'est toi tu es e enfin je veux dire ça
fait partie tant d'individus la
pollinisation les insectes les plans des
milliers fatou bâ ya les manchots qui se
tiennent qui survivent pas ce que parce
qu'ils se regroupent en fait c'est même
un principe de l'évolution biologique
c'est à dire ceux qui survivent sont
ceux qui vous persécutent qui coopère le
plus voilà c'est un principe de
l'évolution un des principes voilà mais
on a pas mille les projecteurs là dessus
et pendant 200 ans en 50 ans on n'a vu
qu'une partie du tableau de ce qu'ont
annoncé qu' il ya une gens on a une
jambe hypertrophié tu vas en culture de
la compétition et une jambe atrophiée
l'altruisme airways pour les naïfs c'est
bisounours le la coopération les
mutualisme ça marche pas en fait non non
seulement ça marche c'est puissant c'est
ça vient spontanément à des expériences
incroyables si tu veux on en parle après
donc nous ce qu'on voulait faire s'est
décomplexé les gens qui pensent ça et
notre livre sur l'effondrement il a
permis de décomplexer un peu dans
certaines sphères cette question de
l'effondrement on peut en parler
maintenant un peu plus librement peut
avancer des chiffres 105 ans prennent
des remarques désagréables dans la dans
la figure et c'est notre livre sur
l'entr'aide ça décomplexe ceux qui ont
cette intuition mais c'est vital cevital
d'arriver à fissurer les imaginaires de
casser cette culture de l'égoïsme 7 qui
te crois que l'être humain et les îles
et spontanément égoïste mais hélas les
expériences sont géniales non seulement
en tant de catastrophes tu as des
tendances pro social extraordinaire mais
en temps ordinaire donc il ya des
économistes qui ont fait des expériences
où ils ont mis autour de la table des
gens et leurs amphis les 10 ou 20 $ et
puis on fait des expériences ils ont
besoin des paramètres il mesure la
capacité pro sociale coopératives ou
égoïstes des gens c'est génial ces
expériences l'expérience de milgram way
à temps et du coup il sur le jeu du bien
public justement où les joueurs
participent au bien commun ils ont
remarqué que ceux qui participaient qui
misaient sur le bien commun y avait ceux
qui misaient ceux qui misaient pas qui
était égoïste et bien ceux qui misaient
c'est ce qui répondait le plus
rapidement alors il se dit assez
intéressant ils ont dit ils ont demandé
aux gens de répondre plus rapidement ils
ont stressé et les gens ont été
globalement plus coopératif puis après
ils ont demandé aux gens de de réfléchir
de prendre leur temps etc et les gens
étaient globalement plus égoïste pareil
notre expérience où ils ont dit il on
stresse et les joueurs en dix ans après
vous devez à faire un exposé devant
plusieurs centaines de personnes j'ai
gagné c'était comme ça et bien au jeu
économique qui sont étaient plus
coopératif quand l'être humain est
stressé il est dans mode intuitif il est
spontanément plus altruiste c'est fou
ok c'est fou sa fille sur notre
imaginaire ça veut pas dire que c'est un
monde de bisounours ça veut dire que si
tu réfléchis tu peux en tubes et on
voyage un voisin le tuer tu peux tu
organisé pour massacrer tu peut coopérer
pour massacrer ton voisin tu en parles
et les guerres c'est ça et justement on
commence à voir larchitecture entre
coopération et compétition comment ça
s'emboîte c'est ça qui est magnifique on
arrive à devenir compétent en
compétition et en coopération et c'est
beau et du coup on peut comprendre donc
ça on a un chapitre là dessus sur la
géopolitique c'est à dire que on arrive
à un moment de l'humanité où le
changement climatique donc la mine deux
des meilleurs moyens de faire coopérer
un groupe c'est de créer un grand
méchant loup un ennemi commun ok ça
c'est classique pour faire une guerre
pour pour ressouder un peuple qui fait
la guerre au voisin tueur oui je sais
c'est que mes pierre connaissent
ajustements dans l'ennemi intérieur dans
la fabrication d'un an et demi vocation
de l'ennemi de l'ennemi superbe ou cas
il parle de tous les moyens de fabriquer
un ennemi aussi pour justement coopérer
bien eh ben
on peut voir le changement climatique ou
la possibilité d'un effondrement ou les
chocs systémiques globo tout ce qu'on
dit là depuis le début comme en fait le
nouveau grand méchant loup qui pourrait
permettre une coopération internationale
l'humanité va enfin se serrer les coudes
pour ne pas mourir en fait pour ne pas
s'auto suicider pour
résister enfin pour survivre ou vivent
plus longtemps au changement climatique
le problème c'est que il ya il manque
plusieurs ingrédients et on les détails
dans livres pour qui et entraide dans un
groupe il faut qu'ils aient sentiment
sécurité qu'on se sente bien avec les
autres dans le groupe c'est pas gagné au
niveau international parce que il on
sait qu'il y en a qui triche il ya les
services secrets c'est le bordel de
sentiment d'égalité d'équité
on en est loin quant à les états unis tu
as cinq pays qu'en droit de veto enfin
déjà c'est pas au niveau de l'onu n'y a
pas du tout d'équité tu as des petits
pays tu as des grands pays 20 pas du
tout de sentiment d'équité mais ça c'est
hyper toxiques pour un groupe le
sentiment d'inégalité ou d'injustice
alors là c'est le c'est enfin ça
provoque un effondrement de la déjà ici
donc j'ai des atouts viennent tous deux
de quoi tu as déjà essayé donc
d'arracher un gâteau
qu'est ce qui se passe
le train de vie américain est pas
négociable c'est ça bon après ça la
question de la dépendance aux drogues
enfin je veux dire dépendance au pétrole
c'est une vraie drogue la dépendance à
la dette des toiles à présent c'est
certain qu'à l'ouvrir esprit futur
adam les troisièmes sentiment c'est
sentiment de confiance c'est juste pour
terminer par rapport
à la
quant à la dépendance à une drogue ça se
petite parenthèse sur le mouvement de la
transition se trouve ça vachement
intéressant si si vous creusez enfin le
modèle de transition à parle bien une
des techniques pour justement se libérer
du pétrole et ils ont été le les prendre
dans les la psychologie de shit ou des
sevrages way des toxicos et c'est
passionnant du coup on fait des groupes
d'entraidé steira et c'est les mêmes au
niveau collectif pipita les mêmes
méthodes de psychologie de jeu pas
comment dire de suivi sur des petits
groupes des petits groupes dans les
transitions quoi c'est toujours des
groupes locaux de quartier etc et tu
peux faire ça et ça ne sert à se
désintoxiquer du pétrole je trouve ça
génial ça permet d'avancer c'est
peut-être pas la panacée mais en tout
cas ça montre bien qu effectivement il y
avait au pétrole fois on est
complètement drogué un truc à un produit
pas cher
enfin voilà le pétrole c'est magique
c'est une source d'énergie magique et
passant pas c'est quoi
une question d'internet nouveau droid ne
vaudrait-il pas mieux accéléré
l'effondrement
ouais c'est une question qui revient
souvent
pour l'anecdote j'avais j'ai été voir le
film demain et tout le monde en parlait
et j'ai trouvé ça ok c'est cool moi j'ai
de plus que j'ai adoré c'est que dans la
première scène quand je fais un petit
détour mais je viens à la question dans
la première scène ils interviewent barre
9 ce qui
pour moi c'est un de mes héros
scientifique qui décrit la possibilité
d'extinction des espèces humaines il est
vraiment à fond collapse vraiment c'est
très chouette ses études et est cyril
dion et mélanie laurent qui
l'interviewent j'ai trouvé ça génial et
les gens hayatou le film qui se passe
c'est la fin du film et joris la ville à
+10
g10 trouve ça fou on applaudit il ya un
gars qui dit attends mais c'est vraiment
possible qu'ils aient une extinction de
l'espèce humaine pour les questions
climatiques 2
juste parce qu'ils sont comme des cons
applaudir je sais pas moi j'ai trouvé ça
fou et du coup je suis allé voir
je suis rentré le soir j'ai mis sur mon
mur facebook j'aime y est ce que selon
vous les solutions parce qu'il parle
bien de solutions mach parle jamais de
solution et solutions du film demain
est-ce que ça sert à éviter
l'effondrement
est-ce que ça sert à le ralentir
ou est-ce que ça sert à l'accélérer
est-ce qu'on réfléchisse si tout le
monde se met à faire des éoliennes enfin
voilà tout ça finalement ça va
précipiter les choses et en fait on va
débrancher les gens d'un système qui va
s'effondrer donc et les résultats ont
été fous personne n'a répondu pour
éviter l'effondrement bon d'accord il ya
un biais d'algorithmes eu facebook je
connais pas et cgu genre 300 réponses ou
où 340 ch et plus mais c'est plein de
gens que je connaissais pas mais la
moitié ont dit ça sert à accélérer et la
moitié ont dit ça sert à ralentir
l'effondrement pour moi c'était
intéressant parce qu'on a vraiment une
photo instantanée de l'imaginaire des
gens c'est à dire qu'on est on est je
pense que ces derniers mois hier il ya
eu un basculement la question de la
possibilité d'une rupture d'un
effondrement elle est beaucoup plus
présente qu'il ya
4 5 ans je faisais des conférences les
gens il était livide à chaque conférence
il y avait des gens qui pleuraient qui
se levait en colère qui était démontée
c'était fou et là ça passe toujours
comme une lettre à la poste au contraire
les gens sont plus heureux je dirais
dans l'enthousiasmé un phénomène de cour
ou i sociaux aussi peut-être il ya un
billet je sais pas mais new wave n'y a
pas que ça enfin cesser d'autres gens
avec qui je parle qui ont ce ressenti
mais ce qui fait plaisir aux gens ce qui
met dans la joie c'est le fait de se pas
se sentir seul parce qu'au début quand
on découvre le sujet on est seul et
après quand on commence à travailler à
malaxer sujet voilà le traité le se
morfondent à y penser et jour et nuit
dès qu'on va voir des gens qui pensent
pareil ça fait un bien fou ça fait un
bien fou il ya une fameuse échelle de
conscience de paul schaeffer cache pas
mais
c'est un colosse au log canadien écrire
un blog magnifique en anglais qui a
beaucoup fait pour populariser tout ça
le choc systémique voilà le collapse
tout ça ils ont l'association hadra
astier a publié un de ces postes il a
traduit en français et ça s'appelle les
genres les étapes de la prise de
conscience et il décrit cinq stades
stade 1 c'est lénine se passe rien il
n'y a pas de problème de façon s'il ya
un problème il suffit de plus de
croissance il n'y a pas de problème
science et la technologie comme jeanne
stade un stade 2 fait plus exactement
faudrait voir mes stats 2 c il ya un
problème gérard holtz
le climat le pic pétrolier non c'est le
nucléaire mais non c'est la finance mais
nantes et qu'on sait les inégalités
n'ont cessé danse et s'il ya un problème
majeur qu'il focus tout et puis à un
moment on passe au stade 3 c'est en fait
non il ya peut-être deux ou trois
problèmes en fait peut-être que climat
et pétrole scellier ah ouais mais non
mais du coup de tête le nucléaire aussi
ouais non mais en fait il ya les métaux
rares et on passe son temps à dans des
réunions à prioriser les a donnés des
priorités aux luttes non ce qui est plus
important c'est changement climatique
menace et nucléaire et puis après on
creuse on creuse on se rend compte que
tout est lié en fait de manière
inextricable
et stade 5 c'est
il ya un effet en fait quand tu te rends
compte que tout est lié ces or ça casse
beaucoup de choses dans l'imaginaire ça
fait des ruptures et le stade 5 c'est en
fait le problème il est il dépasse
l'entendement il rend fou
si tu tombes à la hausse non là tu
reviens au stade
néma parlera après si tu veux des
réactions mais
tu si tu penses trop tu deviens fou et
si tu n'y penses pas tu deviens fou
aussi et le problème c'est qu'à chaque
stade on perd 90 % des gens
tu vois 10 % à 10 % de 10% de 10% on se
retrouve très peu nombreux à être au
stade où on se dit mais en fait ça va
tout changer le futur la représentation
du monde mon rapport avec les autres
humains avec les non humains avec mes
enfants avec ma femme avec en fait c'est
un problème est là tu pars dans la
représentation enfin tout est du coup il
y avait plein de gens qui disent c'est
un chemin spirituel c'est une transition
intérieur d'ailleurs paul schaeffer
qu'at il à arrêter et à genre un an un
an et demi il a dit hey quit il a fait
un post sur facebook il est dit j'arrête
là collapse au logis et il est pris un
chemin spirituel très risque d'ailleurs
est passionnant mais pour michael
ruppert s'est tranché la gorge ouais un
autre chemin mais c'est vrai qu'il
s'était flinguer
du moins les informations que j'ai assez
il a pris sa dague disent ouverts à la
vue qu'il ya eu un reportage à la fac
tchèque est
quelqu'un qui connaisse le leem deux
françaises alors les français
ouais il essayait vraiment intérêt à lui
seul blower fusent mais justement c'est
le destin des cassandres sais c'est dur
d'avoir raison avant tout est bon là
heureusement on commençait de nombreux
c'est pas si dur que ça et je pense
qu'il faut continuer à s'approprier le
sujet il ya plein de jeunes même de
moins jeunes qui commencent à
se décomplexer quoi et ça fait du bien
ça devient je dirais pas de notoriété
publique mais j'ai l'impression que
beaucoup de gens savent et du coup c'est
interdisent d'en parler en public
dans quand on a vu une certaine position
stature enfin j'ai l'impression que ça
s'est retourné que maintenant les gens
le savent et n'en parle plus
volontairement plutôt que ne savent pas
et va et c'est un peu comme les ailes
des vaches avant l'abattoir j'arrête de
faire du bruit
elles savent et un moment elle lâche
alors
il ya un truc qui se passe ces derniers
sert dernier derniers mois
il ya une prise de conscience et c'est
assez massif
on avait dit qu'on parlerait d'un truc
là juste après du coup j'ai perdu la
flûte ou plusieurs nuits sur les
réactions ça aussi c'est marrant parce
que on a fait un chapitre à rendre dans
le bouquin on s'est amusé à décrire les
réactions des gens une fois que tu
commences à y croire il faut que tu
essaies gros déclic eh ben il y en a qui
sont dans la colère plutôt qu'ils ont
qui disent bien fait pour la gueule à ce
système
vivement que ça s'effondre on les a
appelés sava pétiste ça va péter ils
disent tu vois là ça va vite péter bien
fait bien fait et un jour ou l'autre
tout cela
est du coup c'est plutôt un ressentiment
voilà c'est un système inique
dégueulasse et je vais voilà et vivement
alors je sais pas si le à personne ce
inclus dedans mais où se voit en train
de voir le monde s'effondre et je ne
sais pas mais c'est une réaction assez
assez courante y aller il ya ceux qui au
contraire spis bomba attend c'est foutu
allez on va au bistrot on pourrait dire
nous on va boire des verres tant qu'à
faire on va se faire plaisir c'est la
fin voilà qui se trouve être plus sympa
que le piston une [__] pas si tu veux
qu'il y en ait il y en a qui s'embarque
pas mal et y en a qui
justement le côté profiter de la vie qui
le décline dans le mauvais côté c'est à
dire on va faire chier les gens une
dernière fois avant de mourir et du coup
qui se mettent à poux lui à saccager
tout parce que c'est la fin et puis tu
as la réaction et après tu as tout
l'éventail des réactions entre on est
tous dans le même bateau c'est tous
ensemble sinon rien du tout ce que j'ai
appelé ce qu'on a appelé les
transitionnelle c'est un mouvement plus
collectif plus non violent plus
pacifiste et puis la caricature on est
encore dans les caricatures
voilà le bout de l'éventail c'est je
vais me terrer chez moi dans mon mulcair
parce que tout le monde est
potentiellement un danger donc le côté
survivalistes et là dedans il ya tout
l'éventail et je pense qu'on est un peu
tous là dedans quoi le côté tous
ensemble on va plus loin et le côté tout
seul on va plus vite tout est plutôt
tous ensemble on va plus loin que ça je
l'étais très fort au début et lâcher un
peu les deux maintenant j'avoue tout
seul on va plus vite ouais alors ces
moments que si tu peux l'inversé tu es
tout seul on va plus vite ensemble on va
plus loin en fait tout seul vous faire
on fait rien et ensemble c'est le bordel
quand tu es quand tu as mal dormi quand
tu es fatigué parfois c'est un peu ça
bah ouais mais tout est plus que tout
est plus complexe que
que ce qu'on croit
non mais ça risque d'être assez le
bordel quand même et ça il faut aussi
préparer je pense bonnes boucheries
social à l'ancienne question d'internet
comment gérer le nook et 1,7 déchets et
infrastructures dans un monde qui
s'effondre à la question ça c'est ya pas
que les déchets dans le nucléaire en
fait il ya les centrales carrément
piscine au china les piscines les
centrales non mais les réacteurs parce
qu'en fait il faut deux heures pour
éteindre un réacteur il faut quatre cinq
six mois pour le refroidir et pendant ce
temps là il faut de l'énergie il faut
des ingénieurs qui viennent il faut des
voitures pour les ingénieurs et du coup
s'il ya une rupture du route il faut des
routes il faut la paix sociale enfin
voilà et et ça c'est une question
majeure on n'a pas de réponse encore des
trucs édition ouais ouais et il ya des
stocks stratégiques et tout ça mais mais
s'il ya un black out du coup il ya des
pompes les centrales ont besoin
d'électricité
et puis ils ont des pompes aux deux de
sécurité des groupes électrogènes
spécial two en âge qui marche super bien
d'heure on a demandé à des ingénieurs
avec gauthier chapelle et raphaël
d'ailleurs du nucléaire n'a pas encore
trouvé la réponse si jamais il ya black
out électrique et ruptures
d'approvisionnement pour les groupes
électrogènes en pas prévu ce bol ou
alors si un ingénieur qui nous écoutent
s'il a la réponse je suis très friand
parce que j'ai pas encore de réponse
donc ils n'ont pas en fait penser le
risque systémique
d'inde effondrement rapide faire un choc
social politique économique rapide et on
a quand même plus de 235 réacteurs
allumés dans le monde il y en a 400 plus
de 400 en construction mais il y en a 10
58 ou en france ce soit 56 ou 58 en
france france
ouais c'est quand même pour moi voilà
après la question des déchets mais ça
c'est à plus long terme c'est à dire on
peut pas pour moi on peut pas garantir
une stabilité enfin climat climatique
déjà
énergétique politiques
sociales économiques sur sur le moyen et
le long terme et là le problème c'est
qu'on parle de très long terme le
politique les design et pour quelques
années pour la prochaine élection le
ramassage des ordures voilà et là on
parle de de gestion à plusieurs dizaines
centaines milliers millions d'années
c'est c'est fou quand on voit que l'ailé
et les égyptiens on a perdu la trace des
pyramides après quatre mille ans les
pyramides quoi on sait même plus où
elles sont elles sont sous le sable les
retrouve plus
comment tu veux qu'on prévoit la
stabilité
enfin des déchets nucléaires sur des
missiles et c'est les mettre un tableau
tu sais le cri pour prévenir les futures
générations qu'il fallait ouvrir
ouais c'est une grande question
philosophique mais je pense que il ya
beaucoup à faire là-dessus enfin c'est
une grande question pour moi c'est
l'enjeu de notre génération le nucléaire
enfin surtout en france quoi
alors deux questions d'internet apportez
votre soutien une figure politique
actuelle si oui laquelle alors laquelle
on féminin aussi une deuxième question
est ce que l'effondrement de cette
société est vraiment grave pour
l'interrogation sommes nous obligés de
passer par là pour évoluer point
d'interrogation
la première soutient un homme politique
non
un avis sur les politiques bah pareil
que les surréalistes où les transitions
honneur il ya tous les chéquiers ou les
riffs il ya des politiques qui savent
donc qu'ils savent pas de qui croît de
qu'ils croient pas d'autres qui ont un
pouvoir de faire qui font pas d'autres
n'ont pas de pouvoir qui a essaye mais
qui arrive pas il ya plusieurs échelles
il ya de tout il ya des gars super sympa
il ya des [__] voilà ce qui faisait
penser qu'ils ont foiré
enfin moi j'ai été formé par un collabo
logis entre guillemets par yves cochet
celui qui a annoncé en 2008 qui en 2015
il aurait pu de ryanair
lanildut coust ouais bah ouais légale
des noms ouais mais ces prévisions c'est
toujours comme ça mais franchement
il est il a un discours assez assez
clair assez précis assez lucide voilà
c'est intéressant mais c'est pas parce
que tu te goures sur un truc qu'il faut
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain par
exemple gens qui je suis pas d'accord
avec eux sur le nucléaire mais tous tous
qui dit enfin tout le reste est vraiment
pertinent et donc
du coup la question c'était
ouais les politiques même
alors bon en fait je me suis je me suis
je me méfie toujours de ce milieu là
c'est un milieu que j'ai je fréquente
peu et
est naturellement j'ai plutôt tendance à
ne pas m'écouter libertaire ou je sais
pas quoi mais a évité
le milieu de l'entreprise aussi c'est un
milieu que j'ai toujours évité et là
jusqu'au bout pour travailler
c'est-à-dire pour gagner de l'argent oui
bah faut se débrouiller par là je
fréquente un peu plus je termine juste
la phrase un peu plus ces milieux mais
très très doucement juste j'apprends à
les connaître je suis assez prudent mais
pour vivre comment on devient co
l'absolu c'est une question qu'on peut
pas comment corrosion du ressources bah
ouais je suis un chercheur indépendant
ou interdépendants comme on dit mais la
débrouille
les articles en fait c'est moi enfin moi
je suis plutôt un intellectuel donc
comment il fait un intellectuel pour
vivre vendre des articles les expertises
faire des conférences
dans des livres ça gagne pas beaucoup
très peu enfin c'est rare les auteurs
qui arrivent à vivre de leurs
bouquins donc moi j'ai envie pas encore
je fais les conférences j'ai vécu deux
ans
au chômage
grâce au chômage resté longtemps
voilà boucher une famille qui m'aident
des parents une campagne
j'ai économisé un peu pendant un moment
où j'ai de l'argent et surtout la clé
c'est de moins dépenser donc on l'a on
dépense pas beaucoup vraiment pas
beaucoup une fois que tu as réduite et
c'est la priorité il faut dépenser moins
pour travailler moi c'est ça en fait le
truc du coup on libère du temps et par
boucle de rétroaction peut faire des
trucs chouettes il y avait par an un
moment qui me demandait et pourquoi tu
travailles pas jeudi mais j'ai pas le
temps tu vois c'est ça le truc
et on va pouvoir rebondir sur ça
à des budgets aujourd'hui pour
travailler sérieusement sur les
questions de la gestion de
l'effondrement
universités fondation d'entreprise
question d'internet ça c'est une bonne
question j'aimerais bien le savoir
bah ouais parce que moi mon boulot je
trouve c'est de mettre en lien des
différents milieux qui se parlent pas et
aussi bien les universitaires il y en a
qui sont passionnés par ça peut-être
qu'ils vont décrocher des budgets mais
ça c'est leur processus universitaires
des chercheurs des
l'administration des militaires des
assos
écologistes des ja demain mais il ya des
prêtres qui nous city et des anarchistes
et des gens d'extrême droite il de cette
question d'effondrement elle est
transversale à tous et moi ce qui me
tient à coeur et aussi ce qui m'amuse je
m'amuse beaucoup là-dedans en fait c'est
de mettre en lien de bois de tisser du
lien pour pour essayer que les gens se
parlent et se voient là c'est
trouver ensemble et des chemins
apprendre quoi tout est là
[Musique]
je suis aussi critiqué pour ça mais oui
tu critiques bah pourquoi tu vas parler
à ces gens là et eux pourquoi tu leur
parles esterra mais c'est les deux
prennent les étiquettes dont on parlait
tout à l'heure mais
attends j'ai perdu le fil ça commence à
être long on
attend c'est avoir une oreille d'eau
chaude
donc comment ça va pouvoir rentrer dans
le jeu ça chauffe là on commence
quand je perds du fil tant qu'ils t'ont
puis
comme on parlait d acheter comment
parler de l'effondrement au public du
coup questions internet
comment parler elle et les trois quarts
à ce moment là on a répondu à vendre
avant c'était qui est des budgets est ce
que les universités ont des budgets
chose comme ça oui ben moi j'aimerais
bien qu'il ya plus de gens dans l'est
les différents milieux qui se met qui
deviennent chercheurs indépendants ou
pas je m'en fous mais qui trouve des
budgets et qu'ils se mettent à bosser ce
sujet quoi donc un appel au ministère de
la défense n'importe qui mais tout où je
pense devrait voilà moi j'ai un moment
j'ai des articles les et compiler j'en
ai parlé voilà c'est
je pense est accessible à plein de gens
et il ya plein d'intelligence mais mais
qui sont qui sont mal utilisés en ce
moment en plein d'ingénieurs futur je
reçois des messages très touchant de
gens qui disent j'ai écouté une
conférence j'ai dû votre bouquin voilà
je suis je suis je suis ingénieur je
fais un je suis pas un mémoire de fin
d'études en plus techniques ou je sais
pas quoi j'en ai marre ça n'a pas de
sens je vois bien qu'il ya un
effondrement et c'est pas utile de faire
des bagnoles qu'est ce que vous me
conseillez de faire j'en ai reçu des
centaines des messages comme ça il ya
plein d'intelligence qui est là qui
demandent qu'à être
voilà qu'elle a
trouvé du sens donc on a vraiment du
boulot de mettre en lien plein de gens
quoi il faut faire des groupes bloco il
faut se mettre en réseau
question internet penses tu que les
technologies et l'innovation ont un rôle
positif à jouer
les technologies et l'innovation
fred jetées chaque homme sa grosse
question aussi bien là j'aime bien ce
que le travail que fait philippe bihouix
vous l'avez reçu ici
c'est un peu comme ça lui réponds
souvent c'est à dire que
pareil si tu vas vers les low tech c'est
super il ya plein de chouettes
le chemin à prendre l'innovation tout à
l'heure je parlais d'ouest klaxons un
agronome du lundi est situé au kansas
aux états unis il fait de l'innovation
en traction animale de l'innovation
agroécologiques de l'innovation pour moi
de pour moi c'est ça la biotechnologie
c'est d'inventer des machines plus
performantes
en traction animale s'élève c'est fou
c'est une sorte de retour vers le futur
enfin en aide un grand grand déclic dans
l'imaginaire pour moi les low tech ça
fait parti des technologies des
techniques à l'être humain est un e-mail
technique mais allait commencer à
développer de la domotique des maisons
passives ultra technologique du high
tech et des renouvelables high tech je
pense c'est une mauvaise voie la
technique après en général je pense
qu'il ya du bon et du mauvais quoi donc
faut être plus faut être malin faut
encore une fois complexifier la chose et
aller voir au cas par cas ce qui est
pertinent ou pas
il y avait une question que juste avant
tu avais posé le disparu de nos écrans
la zut
comment parler d'effondrement public du
coup ah ouais et ben ouais c'est une
question intéressante parce que du coup
si vous motive les gens à en parler à se
décomplexer moi je pense qu'il faut pas
chercher à convaincre
ce que j'ai appris durant ces années
c'est qui c'est que
ce qui touche en fait c'est de raconter
son parcours
de de raconter comment on a vécu la
chose pas de chercher à convaincre pas
être dans la tête je trouve trouve qu'il
faut raconter les choses vraies
ancrée quand tu es bien dans tes baskets
et bien dans tes idées tu dis les choses
les gens ils sont tout de suite quand
c'est ancré caen s'est aligné
tu t'ouvres et en ouvrant ton coeur je
dirais tu
les personnes en face elle change
complètement et je trouve que c'est plus
apaisé on est moins dans la tête
et on peut parler de chiffres horribles
de show de choses incroyables comme ça
il ya quelque chose il ya une sorte de
magie des fois ça marche des fois ça
marche pas il ya peut-être une
gymnastique un truc à prendre mais je
sais par expérience qu'on peut parler de
ces choses-là en public de manière posée
est calme
ça peut le faire voilà c'est qu'il faut
s'entraîner je ne sais pas peut-être ya
plusieurs manières en tout cas c'est la
mienne et ça marche question d'internet
on voit souvent l'effondrement que
négatifs pour atout en tirer quelque
chose de positif
au programme en plus égalité une
nouvelle économie là c'est une question
un peu large parce que qu'est ce que
veut dire positif pour les uns ça va
être ça pour les autres ça va être ça
mais oui globalement l'effondrement a
fait exprès c'est un mot valise un mot
au but dirait paul ariès qui explose
dans la tête pas récupérable là si le
capitalisme avait arrive à récupérer ce
mot là peut-être qu'il arrive on en est
faut le faire mais
quand on dit effondrement mais les pieds
en place pour moi en tant que biologiste
c'est évident que derrière il ya
renaissance tous les processus
biologiques les écosystèmes quel prix
alors ça c'est dans le monde des humains
dans le monde biologique il ya pour moi
c'est j'ai passé ma manière de penser
c'est ma culture
candy effondrement dit forcément
renaissance et des cycles etc le
problème c'est que dans notre culture le
pas des nantissements dont 1,6 s'il y a
et c'est une possibilité il faut le
penser on le pense dire mais il ya une
possibilité de renaissance aussi et donc
je vais j'ai remarqué justement qu'il ya
plein de gens qui pensent effondrement
sans penser forcément renaissance du
coup il ya tout un travail pédagogique
mais ça je pense que c'est le mythe de
l'apocalypse qui est fort présent tu
vois on a une culture aussi judéo
chrétienne
soit on a le mythe du progrès linéaire
qui est très présent dans notre
inconscient soit c'est un mythe du
couperet du tout a dû la fin du monde en
un jour rogge nautique et puis à rien tu
es une réponse pragmatique
c'était quoi ex tout
moi je pars vite dans la théorie le
positif le positif je voudrais
que chacun voit ce qu'il veut tu
projettes ton imaginaire et on a plein
qui voient ça va être super positif
enfin on va avoir un déverrouillage
massif de plein de trucs qui a empêché
le monde de change est hyper toxiques
dans cette société ça s'effondre c'est
ce que je prends la métaphore que je
prends c'est l'arbre bon désolé c'est
encore théorique mais t'as l'arbre qui
le gros arbres qui s'effondre dans la
forêt
à un moment on sent tu vois on sent
qu'il va il va partir on lâche on lâche
et on passe plus note mais notre énergie
dans les jeunes pousses qui suivent et
c'est parce que le grand arbre tombe que
les jeunes pousses émergent a enfin à la
lumière passons notre énergie
enfin passons du temps à
dans les jeunes pousses dans ce qui
arrive quoi il ya plein de gens en ce
moment qui font des trucs de fou pour
l'avenir pour voilà alors ce qui est
intéressant là dessus
positifs négatifs optimiste pessimiste
moi je dire on s'en fout la posture
c'est ni l'un ni l'autre peu importe
qu'on soit optimiste pessimiste moi j'ai
toujours ça dépend si j'ai bien dormi ou
pas ça dépend des jours ce qui compte
c'est d'y aller de faire d'eux de faire
ce que
tu penses vraiment sincèrement qui veut
changer les choses que tu as envie qui
tue ça apparaisse quoi et donc tu y vas
tu le fais ça peut que dévier le ballon
c'est ton projet
ouais d'un vrai du tout
non au tour de vis sur monsieur le
président pad à vivre le palais
a voté aux dernières élections
comment as tu réussi à te décider à
faire des enfants dans ce contexte
question d'internet question qui revient
souvent aussi cet anodin qui t'a poussé
en fait
alors là c'est à 10 enfin un gamin sinon
c'est terminé
non pas du tout non la décider ensemble
je me souviens un moment dans ma
jeunesse avoir dit que je voulais pas
d'enfants et que c'était pas écologique
tout ça c'est la tête je pense enfin
pour moi en tout cas c'est pas la tête
qui a décidé voilà ça s'est passé un
truc très très profond qui vient et
ça c'est fait super naturellement
heureusement ouais non mais pour
certaines personnes c'est pas du tout
naturel j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
témoignages
qui me disent de tout en fait il y en a
qui veulent qui arrive pas en avoir il y
en a qui disent depuis que j'ai lu votre
livre je connais sur cette question
d'effondrement je veux plus d'enfants il
a même plus d'activité sexuelle
ou tous plus parce que justement c'est
la fin il faut en profiter il ya de tout
franchement il ya du tout pour les
enfants moi je pense que
enfin moi ce que je crois c'est que ils
seront ils s'adaptent en fait super vite
et comme moi je suis plus adapté ils ont
qu'une mes grands parents aujourd'hui
nos grands parents ils comprennent - le
monde d'aujourd'hui la rapidité tout ça
la plupart tout cas dans 30 en 2030 moi
je serais un vieux con réac et mes
enfants et mes petits-enfants ils seront
se débrouiller dans un monde low-tech
dévastée moi je serai là merde comment
on fait pour ça que tous les jours c'est
un bon outil de dévaster 6,6 survivre
jusque là
ouais bah moi j'ai pas demandé à nager
pas choisi de naître à cette époque
qu'est
weck est pas forcément agréable enfin
voilà que tu veux 39
on fait avec ce qu'on a on se débrouille
quoi et auris débrouillons aussi mais il
ya vraiment un élan de vie qui est
intéressant parce que les enfants et par
moi ils m'ont ils m'ont
ils m'ont renforcer dans mes convictions
dans cette dans cette pulsion de vie
d'aider les autres de prendre soin de
moi de me connecter aux non humains au
sauvage c'est pour c'est c'est pour les
enfants qu'on est parti de la ville ont
ils avaient listé jeunes des bébés
commencé à marcher on a envie qu'ils en
avaient envie qu'il soit dans la forêt
tu vois et je pense à beaucoup fait pour
mon parcours pour me stabiliser pour
donner pour donner du sens fin moi ça
m'a donné beaucoup ses enfants je pense
sans les enfants je sais pas si je serai
là aussi poser c'est un sujet quand même
super toxiques bon ils ont ils sont
encore trop jeunes pour que je puisse
leur parler de ça il rentre à peine les
soins maternels voilà
mais je n'hésiterai pas en parler un
mois l'expérience que j'ai du public
jeune
ado 14 ans 13 ans même j'ai fait une
conférence il ya les enfants de 6 7 ans
pétroliers et où on parmi des adultes ça
passe super bien c'est à dire on a
l'impression qu'il faut pas leur dire
qu'il faut leur cachet qu'il faut qu'il
faut adoucir le discours pas du tout je
pense est une erreur je pense qu'il faut
leur parler cash justement être aligné
et les enfants plus que tout le monde y
sentent quand et aligner ou pas et il
déteste qu'on leur mente et qu'on leur
cache des trucs et plus on est franc moi
j'ai une jeune fille avait un public
assez âgées tête 2 300 personnes
c'était en belgique au premier rang une
fille à devais avoir 14 15 ans au
maximum
je finis mâcon et c'est le temps des
questions la première question que c'est
la plus dure
minute de silence et puis elle se lève
la première devant tout le monde elle a
dit merci moi franchement merci ça
motive
merci de votre franchise d'avoir dit les
choses
quand je vois ce que vous faites faux
j'ai de l'émotion j'ai envie de jouer
envie de me bouger et ses toiles et tous
les jeux ea côté il est écrit et c'est
arrivé c'est pas qu'une fois la petite
de 6 ans le lendemain elle raconté à ses
parents elle expliquer le pic pétrolier
et c'est génial que ça que pas assez
génial le pic pétrolier mais c'est
génial de comprendre ça mais c'est vrai
que c'est génial moi j'ai eu des
beaucoup de plaisir j'ai eu des déclics
intellectuelle
énorme ce bouquin ou à cet article ou à
cette hauteur roi cette interview et
j'ai envie de transmettre
cetc déclic que j'ai eus je trouve ça
fascinant enfin voila c'est le positif
dernière question avant de te poser
l'avant dernière question et voilà la
vraie dernière question qu'ils aillent à
21h02 d'autres qu'est sur internet non
ça j'étais parti pour les arts qu'est-ce
que tu tues rajouter quoi en fait
qu'est-ce que je rajoutais
battue le tournoi nom n'a jamais fait le
tour c'est énorme c'est moi on a
effleuré le sujet rentrant tous là je
vous invite à lire le bouquin
non mais pour dire que là on continue
les recherches à dessus donc
fait le tour ah bah non non non non
c'est ça qui est c'est super frustrant
c'est parce que déjà avec le bouquin sur
l'entr'aide pendant quelques mois on a
dû mettre un peu la colère solo j de
côté
le premier tome parce qu'on pense à
plusieurs tome on a accumulé une masse
d'informations énorme et on a mis 10 %
je pense qu'on a 10 10% de ce qu'on
voulait dire à l'époque c'était en 2013
2014 maintenant on a accumulé mais
encore beaucoup de choses il faut mettre
à jour ses données et faut creuser les
autres pistes et dans les pistes des
questions passionnantes sur les causes
de l'effondrement par exemple ce que
nous on sait on s'est d'abord focus et
sur les faits on a été très neutre est
très lisse n'a pas parler de capitalisme
on n'a pas parlé de plein de choses mais
on a voulu s'accorder sur le plus petit
dénominateur commun les faits et après
les gens ils se chamaillent sur les
causes mais c'est une grande question au
collapse aux logiques et puis sur qu'est
ce qu'on fait après ça c'est une grande
question elle n'est pas venue ce soir 1
mais elle elle vient à chaque fois elle
vient à chaque fois qu'est ce qu'on fait
est là tout le monde a sa théorie qu'est
ce qu'on fait bah moi je pense qu'il
faut faire si faire sa fausse acheter
une cabane qu'il faut faire une ville en
transition maintenant il faut aller
voter pour l'europe pour je sais pas
quoi faut élire macro j'en sais rien et
tout le monde a sa théorie est donc
voila nous je pense que les hauts
niveaux collapse aux logiques dans les
recherches en tout cas ça c'est les deux
grandes questions travail et les causes
et du coup travailler qu'est ce qu'on
fait au niveau politique ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la question collective
la question politique en fait mais j'ai
découvert et
j'ai découvert qu'en fait c'est
il faut pas trop se mettre à l'action
rapidement foncer tête baissée action
politique dans l'action politique ou pas
mais valant tu me dis tu me dis que tu
t'éloignes du moins tu refuses la
politique mais tu te tiens tu as quand
même énorme et la politique politicienne
au sens des partis je veux dire le
commun appelle ça les partis politiques
d'un castres
la démocratie représentative telle qu'on
la voit là tel qu'on l'a dans nos pays
c'est un système qui me convient pas qui
est verrouillé qui voit là
pas passé ces dernières minutes à parler
de ça mais je trouve que yalin
deviennent non mais y'a plein de vie et
et il ya des gens qui sont pas d'accord
avec moi il ya des gens qui disent il
faut absolument créer un parti pour
influencer enfin se préparer à
l'effondrement très bien et il y en a
qui veulent réinvestir l'europe très
bien pour moi c'est des échelles trop
grande
il ya on a dépassé un seuil de
convivialité un seuil de taille critique
au delà duquel les outils qu'on a créé
se retourne contre nous c'est un
classique ivan illitch années 70
schoumaker etc et là c'est trop grand
donc il faut rester à taille voilà dans
l'action politique je pense que c'est
intéressant d'investir les la petite
échelle je suis pas
unis si pâle départementale cetera mais
même sans l'administration officielle de
réinvestir le collectif quoi les
manières de faire de faire de la
politique sans les parties et puis non
ce que je voulais dire c'est que ça
c'est tout un chemin déjà
réapprendre le vivent enfin vivre vivre
ensemble s'organiser c'est énorme c'est
des années n'a pas été éduquée à sa
démocratie directe où ça on n'a aucune
idée
faire un potager tu va se retourner
retrouvez des compétences du sauvage
serait en sauvage et
apprendre à faire un potager cinq six
dix ans c'est énorme et puis à toute
cette question qu'on n'a pas trop
aborder mais spirituelle c'est à dire de
transition intérieur de comment on fait
2 comment on fait pour pour rester sain
ne pas devenir fou
c'est aussi un parcours énorme et qui
est très différent et on est super mal
outillés
que ce soit pour les potagers que ce
soit spirituellement soit au niveau des
outils démocratiques
on n'a pas du tout apprécié ça à l'école
dans nos sociétés en tout cas en ville
la majorité des gens et du coup ça met
des années à acquérir ça et on n'a pas
ces années c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'il faut s'y mettre sur tous les
fronts
autant
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps je pense
que nous de notre vivant va on va notre
vie va complètement changer c'est pas
pour nos enfants c'est pour nous quoi
donc là on est relativement protégé dans
né en france
dans nos pays c'est qu'il ya un couche
un vernis technologique enfilé souci un
filet social ou économique ou dans de la
dette c'est super fragile au niveau
financier aux financiers et ça peut
faire des contagions assez rapidement
sur l'économie sur la politique avec des
boucles de rétroaction effet domino qui
veut bien ouais avec le climat là dedans
qui met tout en tension la géopolitique
et qui peut prendre que moi c'est comme
ils disent alors oui dans system
overstreet ch
hypertendus et james howard kunstler tu
vois ce qui a fait le zoo l'ong
emergency
collapse hologue américain il fait on
est claustral fac c'est une expression
militaire pour dire c'est foutu faut
battre en retraite
ben ouais ça va ça va être dur mais ça
va être dur mais voilà si on avait la
certitude que ça arrive pas on ferait
rien si on avait la certitude que ça
arrive que en 2050 il ya plus l'humanité
ferait rien ce qui compte c'est
l'incertitude c'est pour ça qu'il ya une
pulsion de vie une pulsion de mort c'est
pour ça que on va se bouger et on ne
sait pas du tout ce qui va arriver
tout est ouvert
patrimoine je sais que vous dise comment
on sécurise pas je sais que le sport
mais j'ai pas grand chose j'ai inventé
but enfin c'est plutôt gpad mire
solide en faire même pas notre porte
et
voilà j'ai une bagnole des roms montagne
s'est pour l'instant très utile j'ai une
carte bancaire je vais au supermarché de
temps en temps
non enfin moi je pense que les
compétences parler de vie ce retour à la
vie sauvage mais il ya d'autres
compétences super importante
à prendre l'avion en collectif je pense
qu'il ya deux domaines aussi essentiels
bon ça c'est assez personnelle mais je
pense qu'on aura besoin c'est un
le de côtoyer les réfugiés
d'apprendre justement ça apprend
l'empathie ça apprend à accueillir sa
apprendre à se mettre à la place des
autres parce que peut-être dans dix ans
et nous tirons gratter aux barbelés de
la norvège ou du danemark pour avoir un
asile politique on n'est jamais à l'abri
dont on ne sait jamais donc pour moi
allez
allez toucher
cette question vivre avec c'est
important et c'est une pratique ça met
des mois et des années à tu vas être à
l'aise avec ça c'est vraiment dire allez
voir les anges où est né à bayonne
surtout chez des tomates l'a dûment
l'avion pour y aller mais non non mais
ici il ya déjà des gens enfin la vallée
de la roya mon frère habite à laval et
de la rouille à la basse et enfin c'est
du sérieux les dés jeune erythréen qui
mineurs qui passe l'école sans blouson
il fait moins 15
et ils ont ils ont deux ans dans des
pays pas sympa du tout c'est vraiment
dur donc moi je pense que ça apprend
beaucoup sur ce que c'est que vivre un
effondrement s'il ya des gens en ce
moment là des pays des régions des gens
qui sont déjà en train de vivre qui ont
vécu cet effondrement est donc sortir
notre bulle de confort et puis là de le
deuxième la deuxième chose qui paraît
essentiel pour comme savoir à acquérir
ces les soins palliatifs et
l'accompagnement des mourants et l ess
confronté à la mort elle est accompagnée
des gens développer des capacités
d'écouté d'empathie pour moi c'est
essentiel pour le temps qui viennent on
n'est pas du tout habitué je dis on
c'est la majorité des gens dans notre
société pas tous hein mais
moi en tout cas je suis pas du tout
formés à ça et j'ai pas d'expérience de
la mort et ça je pense ça va servir
il ya des unités de soin palliatif
volante si vous voulez vous formez
il y en a plein en ce moment et qui se
baladent parce que ça coûte moins cher
de laisser les yeux crevés à la maison
une question tu vas pas pouvoir leur
répondre mais je vais imposer quand même
faut-il investir dans l'or les crypto
bonnet b chine et ça ça m'intéresse pas
mais je sais qu'il ya plein de forums
sur internet pour moi lors c'est une
fois c'est une devise comment dire c'est
une valeur refuge refuge merci mais
juste
pendant les crises financières quelques
jours quelques semaines fin c'est un
truc pour retrouver ses billes mais à
long terme c'est rien investi dans des
graines à planter des graines à semer la
haine quand tu vois la grèce ans il ya
quelques années au ca c est un collapse
quand même financiers économiques
sérieux ils ont fermé des hôpitaux et
tout ça les échanges de graines et
potager collectif s'était pas c'était
pas pour faire bisounours là en syrie
aussi il ya eu des jets que le fait
qu'ici les ans pour ce show fut la bonne
mais c'est du sérieux le fait qu' il ya
plus de financement plus de retraite les
médecins sont pas payés et ben les ya eu
autogestion dans le quartier de gens
pour maintenir ouverte une maison de
santé de quartier enfin c'est du on est
dans le dur en grèce on a emmené en
syrie il ya des jardins partagés en
ville qui ont été créés des bourses
d'échangé de graines et tout donc quand
tu arrives dans la merde quand à la
maternité regrets s'il fallait payer
sinon et donnait pas le gamin
j'avais pas fais ça tu m'as vu des
milices puis on a revu des pathologies
qu'on avait plus vu depuis des années
saul
non mais attends il ya trois manières de
mourir en masse
hier maladie famille on n'y manquera pas
c'est les trois manières qui a de mourir
en masse
le climat le pic pétrolier tout ça c'est
des mots gentils théorique les chiffres
de scientifique mais tout ça c'est des
effets de contagion qui débouche
toujours sur trois choses guerre maladie
et famine et les trois sont
interconnectés et se nourrissent l'une
l'autre il peut y avoir des causes
climatiques
dès qu'on n'arrivera pas à dénouer
toutes les causes mais ça termine
toujours comme ça c'est sûr que si on de
plus personne pour sénou déchets dans
des villes ultra concentré ça va être
compliqué de se préserver des épidémies
est ce que tu es un conseil pour les
jeunes générations
par un conseil c'est juste
désolé je m'excuse est désolé pour tu
vois si on met une bouteille à la mer et
qu'on la retrouve en 2050 ou en 2100 si
jamais à quelqu'un qui l'a retrouve
s'est
désolé les gars on est parti trop vite
on n'a pas arrangé on n'a pas remis les
choses en place m'a foutu un bordel
monstre et
bon courage c'est ça dont vous êtes
ouais bon courage en vous aime désolé tu
vois quelque chose à rajouter
pablo serving merci merci coupé
[Musique]
holmes